Only 5 minutes of training left.
Wait a minute, I'm not sure it's empty.
I'll just make this video bigger.
Where she told me one of her friends is not allowed to be abused
It is.
Maybe, and any problem with one of them
orpho
was even more hurtful than I thought.
YAY!
希...
Hello!
Welcome everyone to the swing!
I'm gonna just call over that one up up there.
Oh that was real smooth.
That was real smooth, sorry.
Oh god.
Okay, so who's gonna try?
I'm a muppet.
Yeah, I place the muppet where you look like you're controlling the muppet.
It does look like I'm controlling the muppet, thank you.
Anyway.
Should we introduce ourselves?
Yeah.
Who goes first?
Okay, oh god, okay.
Hello, I am Apollo Mythos and I am underneath a mythos here with Poseidon 2.
Wee, I am the goddess of the sun.
Wee, yay!
Pachi, pachi, pachi, pachi, pachi.
I can't clap with these controllers.
Oh god, well decided.
Oh, is it my turn?
Yeah, I was like, I'm done.
You have more to say.
I mean, I don't know what to say, I'm the goddess.
Oh no.
Hi, my name is Poseidon and I'm very wet.
I'm gonna have to agree.
Yeah, yeah, I agree.
I went out there for just one second and came out like, oh, I'm soaking.
Oh, this is how it's gonna go.
I'm excited then.
Hi, my name is Sheevee Cottonbum.
Hello, your Dom.
I was gonna come up with a Rizz line, but forget it.
But you can call me anytime.
Don't tell me that.
I'm gonna start calling you like four in the morning.
That is totally okay, I'll pick up for you.
Better keep your word, I'm gonna call you.
Great, I'm already being bullied by the chat.
Just as planned.
Oh yeah, and I stream on YouTube with Veeler, hey.
Yeah.
Hello, my name is Mercy Modiste.
I am the dorky yandere of Veeler's Gen 1 Indulge.
Pleased to meet you.
Screaming for mercy.
Oh my god, do it again.
Wait, are you screaming for mercy?
Because I can moan for you if you want.
I will never say no to that.
Oh my god, that was so hot.
Would you like that?
Oh my god, I'm melting already.
I feel like I'm in bamboo zone.
Give me a second, I need to clean up.
I need a towel.
Man, I love this mix here.
I see, I see.
Shimei has discovered.
Oh my god, I don't know how to play this.
You guys wanna start now?
Yeah, let's start, let's just lean it.
Nothing like some good scuff around here.
Have a good time.
Thank you, Todette.
Thank you for, don't tire yourself out.
Do you guys have a favorite Mario character?
Toad!
I found a shadow.
I can't do it.
Mario Party.
It's gonna be my first time playing this one.
It'll be fun, I love this version of Mario Party.
It's really fun.
It was the Seisho Apollo stream so far.
Wow.
I already broke the Seisho.
Why?
Apolly of a Mickey impression?
That's right everybody.
Give me a second, I need this.
Listen here little lady.
You and I tonight.
Gosh Apollo, I didn't know you were so talented.
You should listen to many.
Oh boy.
I gave it to her real good.
I know, I was watching this.
Okay.
I can be Mercy again.
Oh, I'll be.
Mercy all.
Yay.
Rosalina's my girl.
Wait, no, I don't wanna be the monkey.
I have to click while I'm reading.
Don't look at me like that chat.
Stop it.
That's gonna be a clip.
Fuck y'all.
Chibi, I think you're thingy is still on.
You're like, reverb?
Is it?
I turned it off.
Did you guys select your character yet?
Click A.
There we go.
Smart.
Hi, thank you so much.
Wow, little chibi.
Oh, it's lagging.
Oh no, shit.
The connection is unstable.
Why?
Who's toaster is connected?
Mine's fine, I'm good.
Alright, there's four maps.
So we have,
we have Yoshi's Tropical Island,
Space Land,
Peach's Birthday Cake.
I want the cake.
You want the cake?
So there's like little Bowser's Island
and if you land there,
like basically just
ruin your game.
You guys want the birthday cake?
Sure.
I want cake.
Give me that cake, girl.
Oh yeah, it's the host, it's the host.
Oh my god, it's me.
The cake by the ocean.
Okay, it's recommended to do 15.
So it's so baby.
What is this lag?
I love cake.
I'm so hungry now.
I just want a cake.
I'm dying.
Okay, hold up.
Why the fuck are you dying?
I'm dying.
The internet down here in Atlantis is good.
Oh no.
The scoff is real.
And we just started this shit.
You think with all the internet wires
underwater
that you have amazing
connection.
You're a sexy Muppet.
Why are you questioning my Muppet hood?
You in the chat, shut up.
Hell yeah.
I suck my Muppet.
Nevermind.
I can do any games.
Okay.
Let's go.
We're back, baby.
Put it in my ass.
What?
What do you say about your ass?
Mario.
That's a good peach.
Put it in my bum-bum.
Oh my gosh.
What are you talking about?
I'm so cute.
It is such an adorable map.
I love this map.
Oh, it's so cute.
Our very special princess.
I need to take off my pants for this.
So cute.
Take off your pants.
I know. I usually don't.
I don't.
Oh, what are we celebrating?
My birthday.
I'm just kidding.
Happy is early.
It's Friday.
Happy early birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Toad is in charge.
Who put Toad in charge?
Toquish it.
How do you use your voice
not heard after?
I don't know.
I'm pretending and I'm like,
wow, I really, I really,
really heard my voice.
Okay, let's see the instructions.
Oh, it's so cute.
I'm going to eat this cake out.
What?
Eat me out instead.
I'm just kidding.
I'm not kidding.
We weren't.
This looks so fun. I've never played this.
You don't want to end up over here, by the way.
You don't want to end up where Bowser's at.
That's some flan.
That's so cute.
I kind of want to be with Bowser.
Bowser is kind of home.
Physically is.
Physically, emotionally.
Okay.
When I went to go watch the Mario game,
in the faders,
when Bowser came out, I was like, Daddy?
Wait, everybody heard me
and I was going back.
Oh, does this not use gyro control?
Shit.
I was going to push the air.
Oh, no.
There you go.
Oh, I was to pay attention.
I forgot to tweet that I'm live.
Oh, God.
I'm first.
Oh, my.
That's fucking old.
I'm just one out there.
Man.
I'm sorry, Mercy.
It's over.
You're last.
You're the best for last.
Many games. I'm so horrible.
Many games.
Yay.
What is that?
Yeah.
Well, we know how to play Mario Party.
Okay.
Just stop this version.
I thought it was your first time playing Mario Party.
It is for me.
Okay, it's for...
Yeah, it is for me.
I know.
I'm taking...
We're popping her Party Cherry.
Party Cherry.
We're so honored to be your first.
Oh my God.
Oh, that's in a group.
It's beautiful ladies.
Here we go.
OK.
Oh, OK.
So you're going to click the dice block.
You can check the board if you want.
OK.
It's like whipping out the fucking wrap.
Oh, so Claire's looks so good.
And the wafer looks so good.
This is beautiful.
Oh, no.
I want to eat this.
I have some Korean pastries next to me.
And I'm going to snap.
I'm trying to figure out how to do this.
She'll click the ice block.
There you go.
OK.
You just roll a number.
Oh my God.
You'll move two spaces.
You move two spaces to the board game.
Oh my God.
I'm so proud.
Thank you.
Yeah, it's my fucking turn.
OK.
Fuck.
I am so sorry.
My fat ass came from behind and fuck bumps me there.
No.
Let's go.
Dude, do you guys see that?
They pushed me right in.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
I'm so sorry.
That's OK.
I liked it.
I hate that it doesn't have gyro controls.
I'm so sorry.
I don't know how to set up this.
Oh, damn.
What's this?
We're just knocking everybody out.
Damn.
I wish I had apple juice.
He's big or small.
I don't know how big.
It's like a strawberry.
I love strawberries.
Sure.
What is it?
I feel like this is going to be a bad thing.
Oh, it is.
Oh.
Now that's a healthy strawberry.
I don't think that's a strawberry.
Oh, no.
Great.
When a opponent lands on the space, the strawberry will still coins.
I don't think strawberries look like that.
Me game time.
Oh.
Rapid river rain.
Oh, I hate this one.
Huh?
I don't know any of the minigames.
What's this one?
Oh, OK.
What's the?
Is that all right?
OK.
Oh, my God.
I'm ready.
I'm about to fucking.
Oh.
I never mind.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
You know, we should probably start.
Ah.
This is our practice.
The leg is so.
OK.
It's so bad.
Sorry, guys.
I'm serious.
The connection is unstable.
We know.
Yeah.
Sorry, it's the Atlantean Internet.
I can't.
I'll be ready.
It's like sabatole.
It's OK.
You know what?
It's just a little more challenging.
I think I got the gist of it, though.
You burst out a little plus.
Oh, that's me.
That's me.
I don't have drift on my controllers.
Hello.
I love you so much.
I'm screwed.
Apple juice, Tom, baby.
I wish I had that right now.
I'm ready.
Let's go.
Zooming.
Oh.
It's harder than I thought it was.
I know.
The controls feel so sensitive.
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
What the heck?
And I know I have drift on one of my controllers.
I feel like I can never really get the middle one.
No.
What?
Please, please let me through.
Let me in.
Speed the flick up.
Oh my god.
I did it.
Yeah.
Squeeze it in.
Second place.
It's to me, Marcio.
Hey, if this was Mario Kart, y'all would be wiped.
I know.
I'm so bad at it.
I'm disgusting at Mario Kart.
I can't do that.
That isn't good, by the way.
I know the people out there that don't know what that is.
Oh, no.
Oh.
Robbed.
I'm right here.
All right.
We got this.
High numbers.
Okay.
Never mind.
It was robbed.
Oh my god.
No.
I hate you and your dumb strawberries.
All my money.
No.
What?
I couldn't give it out of mercy.
I can't believe you.
I thought you were my sister.
I am your sister.
What's yours is mine and what's mine is, well, mine.
Oh, I can also plant a strawberry.
No.
Yes.
I wonder what a large one would be.
I'd probably take your stars, maybe.
Oh, dang.
Snore princess, let's go.
Shut up.
There's a lot of coins.
Okay, okay.
Mario.
Please, please.
Please land on my strawberry.
I'm begging.
That sounds funny.
No.
Plump, sweet and begging for cream.
Are you going to plant another one?
No.
Are you kidding me?
I'm about to steal all your money.
You don't want me to pick you up, princess style.
Maybe if it includes rewards.
Oh.
Hello, honey.
What is this?
Are you destroying bills that I need to pay?
Oh, no.
What is this?
Oh.
All right.
This is all about timing.
It's all about timing.
Oh, I see, I see.
Oh, do I try to hit you guys?
Oh, I see.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're OK.
Oh, OK, I get it.
I get it.
I'm really bad.
Oh, that's going to be hell.
I'm really bad at it as well.
Yeah, it is just timing.
Oh, I'm going to be so bad at it.
Let me fire.
Oh, God.
Stop.
Well, goodbye, cruel world.
How long are you guys going to do the practice?
Are you guys going to do the little thing?
I want to.
We're going to mong my mythos over here.
Yeah, I know, right?
What can you expect when a bunny girl in a yonder
and go up against gods?
Nothing.
I suck at this.
I just want to survive.
This is not going to go well.
What?
No.
I keep missing.
Are you lying when you say you haven't played this game?
You're pretty good.
I haven't hit a single person.
I'm going to be the first one dead.
OK, I got one.
No.
Oh, shit.
Time, time, time.
No.
Oh, I blocked it.
Damn.
Oh.
You almost got caught.
Oh, oh, oh.
I love the two FPS.
Oh, I'm dead.
Wah.
No.
Sorry.
Oh, no.
Avenge me, Mercy.
This is going to be hard to learn.
You're on that diagonal.
Mercy, Mercy's Apollo.
Oh.
Ah.
I've been funny or feel like I missed each other for like five minutes.
Constant.
Hold on, Ellen.
She beats volume if she's a little loud.
I'm so sorry.
It's OK.
It's my own adjustments, too.
How about now?
Hello, hello.
My name is Shibi Kahnbum.
I'm your favorite summon day tricks bunny.
Don't you want to give me a kiss?
Yes.
Mmm.
Ah.
Don't do it.
Oh, no, don't do it.
Do it.
No, don't do it.
What the hell?
Hello.
OK.
As long as she sounds good now, I'm so sorry.
That was me on my end.
I can't believe you've done this.
Yes.
Wow.
I hate my life.
I'm so bad at impersonation.
Let's see how fast I die.
Oh, thank god.
Oh, I need some luck.
Oh.
Damn.
Oh, snap.
You got your money back.
Let's go.
It's my turn.
I forgot you can emote in this game.
Can I?
You can?
Yeah.
Hold on.
What?
Oh my god.
I can't afford the star.
How much is it?
No.
It's like 30, I think.
No, I can't afford it.
Come on.
Who the heck was that voice?
Eh.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Wait, wait.
Who's strawberry's that?
It's my strawberry.
Oh.
It gave you a smile and money.
Mush pit.
Oh, it's a mosh.
It's a mosh.
I don't even know what a mosh pit is.
I'm going to smash all of you.
No.
Oh, no.
We have to run.
I literally like died.
So we go like, what?
Do we jump?
You hit the block.
Yeah.
Block to find the mushroom.
Sorry.
This is going to be hard for me because I have no sense of, you know.
Oh, thank you very much.
No.
I'm running.
Dang it.
It's going to take a while.
I also have terrible depth perception.
I'm running.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that was a real game.
Oh, God.
I'm big.
Wait, you can ground pound?
Nice.
That's not the only pounding I want.
Let's scream.
Please be gentle.
Oh, jump me.
Guys, why don't we start the game?
No.
I wasn't even looking and I killed you guys.
You steal.
Are you kidding me?
Beginner's wall.
I choked.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry, hair.
My choked.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
I am at the bottom still.
How do you should be?
I'm normally atop, so this worked out.
I like tell my dad all the time.
I'm like, I'm a switch, guys.
I swear.
I don't know.
You're the bottom.
You shut the fuck up.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm ready.
Can I get a little thingy, my barber?
Can I like plant a strawberry?
I hate it here.
Oh, now I'm third.
I've been getting nothing but robbed.
Robbed of my wins.
Damn.
It's OK.
Oh, it's me.
It's me.
Please.
Oh, my God.
No.
Oh.
Cute.
Hey, yeah.
Lucky space.
Watcher just gives you a star.
I would like just throw my switch across the room.
No, don't throw it.
Double the dice.
Damn.
That's really good.
Nice.
It's a my turn.
It's a mercial time.
Fuck.
I knew you were going to get a one.
I felt it in my bones.
Well, Shabee's rage-sick over this game.
More likely than not.
Oh, great.
Oh, my God.
All right.
Are you serious?
Well, well, well.
OK.
The world hates me right now.
Wait, I don't know.
Don't never mind.
I don't.
I'm not ready.
Oh, do I have to, like, pull it?
Oh, we like.
Great.
One, two.
This is OK.
Hold on.
We're going to have to get a very lucky.
I'm pretending this is my harem's nipples.
Oh.
We're losing so badly right now.
So I'm trying to, like.
I think I'm ready.
I think we should start.
I'm ready.
We're not ready.
Thank you.
What the hell?
Why are we not rotating the note?
Why are we losing?
You hear that?
Yeah.
How do you know how to rotate this damn thing?
Yes.
I'm rotating.
I'm rotating past.
Oh, no.
I took it off.
All right.
I'll let you guys win so we can start.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, we're doing it.
We're doing it.
Let's go.
She's not touching it.
I'm not touching the sticks.
I'm not touching it either.
Am I the problem?
Oh, wait.
I'm the problem.
Holy shit.
We're so screwed.
Oh, my gosh.
This is going to be the rest of the stream.
Okay.
Sorry.
I need this.
Give this to me.
Why are you in a Bowser costume?
Because I'm strong.
Oh, my gosh.
We got a rage.
Oh, hi.
Hello, Reflings.
I'm still at the bus.
Cece, you know, keep in mind that's how I'll play with your fucking nipples chat.
Don't look at me.
Go get it twisted.
Somebody in my cat.
She just said we lost to a furry.
I'm not a furry.
We love furries.
Get in the furries.
I mean, you've got your tails and stuff.
Please, I'll do our best Scottish accent.
Shit.
Nobody goes.
Oh, shit.
I had the chance to change your face.
Would you?
Yes.
Play.
I just love the fondle of bosom.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, shit.
Oh, wait.
It's when you...
I was 30 for some reason.
Oh, thank you very much.
I'll be taking that yonk.
Yonk?
I love it.
I'll be taking that yonk.
Yonk?
I think Rosalina...
What the hell?
No, she didn't speak.
Yeah, it sounded like a little more mature.
It's like...
It's mine.
Bye, mom.
Let's go.
Wait, I need 22.
Yeah, you thought I was losing?
You guys don't know how competitive I am, chat.
I'll probably sit my drink.
No, I do not.
I do not have that sun draft.
I'm a beacheress.
I literally threatened my community
if I was beating them up.
If you ever need help doming,
I have a leash.
I have a whip.
Oh, my God, let's double team them.
A whip?
Literally, I have the same thing.
I got me a little mini paddle for them.
I'm already at the bottom.
A mini paddle.
I got a mini paddle.
I like swimming.
10 coins?
Choose a seed?
Which seed do you choose?
Who's seed will you swallow?
What is it?
No!
Wait, no, I'm okay with it. Daddy Bowser.
The mini paddle hurts more than the big paddle.
I'm making sure you get pain.
I thought you played this before.
Come on.
Bring it.
Okay, baby.
Yeah, dodged all of those.
Write that down.
You have a chance.
Oh.
Where are you?
It's your people.
What the frick?
Wait, what?
Okay, let's see.
Bee?
What the fuck are you doing?
Oh, we speed up the flower.
Okay.
We speed it up until they chase you.
So we need to do it?
We need to have timing.
No!
Yeah, and then we all go one at a time.
Okay, I get it.
Oh, my God, Tretch.
Alright.
Okay, I think I get it.
She was a skater, girl.
She said to you later, girl.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Yeah.
Alright.
As long as we're in different timings,
we can make her run.
Run, girlie.
Run!
Alright, I get the timing right.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Bear me.
Bear me, bear me, bear me.
Spider.
I'm Spider.
Oh, what?
Now it's faster than us.
I can't.
Come on, we're so close.
How long is this thing?
She's gonna make it.
You're probably gonna win.
Oh, my God.
Oh, shit.
Good job.
I was so focused, I was like...
Mythos are gamers.
Let's go!
Nice.
I have enough to afford a star now.
Woo!
I'm no longer broke.
No.
Oh, no.
This is a game, definitely.
I want one.
I was hoping she would accidentally say no thanks.
She was like, oh, I haven't played.
I don't need this, right?
I actually don't know if I need it.
I just wanted to.
You do need the stars.
The stars is what makes you win.
Yay.
There's just one coin ahead of me.
A bench space.
Wait, that's cheating!
What?
Wait, what do you mean that's cheating?
Wait, wait a second.
How far away is that?
I didn't mean to...
I want to look at the board.
You don't know what I'm doing.
I'm just a little chicken.
Oh, yeah.
I already know.
Daddy is going to be robbing me.
I think you're good.
Oh, no, I think I'm going for another turn.
It's fine.
You made it.
It's a my turn!
That's a goal!
Motherfucker!
Damn.
I'm going to use coins.
Yes!
Oh, no.
A few.
No world.
World me, baby.
You spin me.
Oh, what is this?
This is wine!
I'm so excited.
I already won.
Wait, what is this one?
Okay, I think I did it.
Oh, damn!
She got it.
Why is everyone so gamers?
My thumb hurt.
Oh, what?
I know exactly what she's doing.
What am I doing?
I'm not going to say.
You're ready!
What?
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm ready, let's go.
Oh, God, I'm going to lose.
I need to hold my switch in a different way.
Oh, damn!
I think I figured it out.
No!
I couldn't button mash.
Oh, no!
My hand cramped up.
No!
Man, I wish I had a 30-60.
Oh, my!
It's okay, it's fine.
Everything is okay.
My finger action is just that good, baby.
Damn!
Dang girl, you're good with your fingers?
Yeah, I'll show you later.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, God.
Sweetie, sweetie, I'm coming for that peachy booty.
Don't you worry.
Damn!
Oh, thank you.
Yay!
I'm getting my ass handed to me.
Are you okay?
At least you're not on the bottom.
I hit it, block!
It's okay, as long as I talk to you.
Wait, what?
Okay, oh, yay.
Uh, it's so annoying.
Pat the game?
I don't know how to do that.
I'm not that smart.
How is she winning?
I'm flying!
I really, this is my first time.
I swear, please.
Thanks.
I say the same thing every single time in bed.
It's my first time.
Oh, my God.
No!
You're robbed!
Why does Mercy just keep robbing you?
Mercy!
I love your money!
Thank you!
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna cry.
I should wait for the warp block.
Oh, my God.
It's, I swear, I never done it before.
You gotta believe me.
Why does that sound like a lie?
But it's not a lie.
I don't know.
I swear, I'm not lying.
I feel sorry for you, almost.
He starts pounding you.
Baby!
He just blows your bag out.
I feel like I'm gonna take a few coins.
Wait, he just gave me money!
Money!
That was really nice of you.
I want to take his load.
You gotta wait in line like the rest of us, God!
Damn!
There's a huge of lies.
Guys, I need art of all of us in Bowser's stat.
Thank you, chat. Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Although, Mercy is very innocent.
She can be in, like, the chair off to the stud.
She's the one who wants to participate.
She's just observing.
Yeah, she's learning.
She's rude.
The cooner.
Okay, fine. She's front and center.
Yeah!
Mercy gonna be watching with that camera.
She's taking it like a champ.
I want to buy.
Also in the chair.
What's a warpline?
Hello, thank you so much for following, honey.
I'm gonna teleport you to somebody else's.
Oh.
I'll take Double Dice.
Imagine if it's two ones.
If it's two ones, I will cry.
I am committing in Minecraft.
Committing?
Yeah, I say committing.
Suicide all.
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
No.
Not the water.
What's this one?
Are you playing golf?
Golf?
What?
Oh, this is golf.
Oh, okay.
I love golf, sort of.
Nice.
Nice shot.
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
Cock.
I'm a natural.
Natural having cock?
Yes.
Oh, because she's a pollo.
I'm struggling because the connection is unstable.
Oh, no.
It's fine.
I did not see that.
I was lagging so bad.
Oh, so that's how you do.
Oh, my God.
Are you kidding me?
Hold on one, baby.
The slow motion.
Slowly cross up.
Yeah. Fuck. Oh no! I can't even fucking calculate it. Can I have another practice?
I'm so sorry. Oh, and it changes each time. Oh, I get to go first. Joy. Let's see if I'll
still get lag. You got it! I believe in you! Oh. How about the edge of glory? Is there wind
speed? Should I be accounting for wind? How do we do the power thing? Oh. The power? Oh,
you move your joy card up and down as opposed to left and right. Yeah, your little ring.
The power. Oh, the wind was there. That was the wind. The wind took it. I didn't realize!
There has to be wind because the flag moves. Oh wait, no, it's just lagging.
It's the lag. It's the lag. Amazing. Oh God. Please. She's gonna blast it off because of the lag.
Damn. Oh. Oh. I'm in hell. I'm ready. I don't get it still. Give me one second. Okay. Give me one second.
Give me one! The connection is unstable. The connection is unstable. I'm mentally unstable. How
about that? Okay, I think I'm ready. If this is fine, this is I'm ready. I understand. I'm eating
bueno. Candy boys. Hopefully it just lags in the practice. Sorry. What are you eating?
A bueno. A bueno? A bueno. I want one. Yes. I go first. Okay, sorry. Oh, sorry. I missed
this tip. Someone said, thank you for the $1 tip anonymous. Like Poseidon and Icy would be good
friends. Icy has her OG fans Poseidon has her daddy. Oh, my God. Oh, no. Oh, my God.
All in one. Did you get that with lag? I'm cooked. I don't have a chance. I'm done. I'm not even gonna try.
Oh, damn. That's pretty close. I'm such a gamer. I blame the lag, bro. I haven't played yet. I'm sorry.
I am my turn. It's a lag. Sorry. I don't know who to find out. It might be the eels that live next door.
The lag is real. Oh, I'm in pain. Oh, my God. Oh, my God. Call me Tiger Woods, the way I'm about to chop down this
truth. That doesn't make any sense. I didn't get it, but you had the spirit. I was trying. I was trying really hard. I
need to get a cookie. I'll be right back. A cookie. Yeah, I'm hungry. I just had Korean black noodles. No, so what
am I meant to do? Are you kidding me? Yeah, you can have some. Please don't be. I hate this game. Why did you pick it?
I didn't pick anything. I got to talk a little earlier. I did, but I get hungry. I just get hungry. I love you.
Food is my personality. I love the lag. We love lag in this house. This is the best part.
Slow-mo disappearing. Kind of like dramatic. I'm charging up my final attack. Wow, that's just like a whole 30
seconds. Oh, I'm fainting. I'm so dramatic. Where's my mouth open? A fly is going to fly in. And other things. Has
that happened before? Yeah. I had my mouth open and I was like, I'm concerned. I can't tell what's
happening. I can't either. Everybody's just on the floor except for me. This is just the Mario Party
experience. I'm just kidding. No, it's not. I have so many coins. You have so much money now. I do. Here we go. I'm
going to freaking lose it. I swear to God. Is this my money? No. Are you serious? Don't do it. Don't do it. Dang it.
Let's drop her. Who's gone now?
But, but, but, oh wait. Oh, no. Paul is back. I'm sure. I'm here. I'm here. My life is over. I was going to do a big one, but I was like,
nah.
Me too.
Shit. Wait. Wait, you got the lucky one. It's fine. Actually, I'll type that back.
What is that do? Oh, that's not lucky. That's not lucky. It's not. Well, no, it could be used. Let's say I'm like, I'm like right close to the star or like close to something. Now you get by it. Yeah, I'm unlucky.
First, just like me. I'm first. Oh, snap. Oh, snap. I have my sword. I feel powerful.
I thought it was going to lag and you accidentally were going to click no.
It like just froze for me for like a split second. Oh, no.
All right. This noise is all yours. Take it and shove it up your butt. Did you say the butt? The butt. Up my butt.
Yeah, that's a good one.
It's a mine turn. Let's go. God, fucking damn it. Wait, nah, that's good.
Oh, I'm like, I'm like, go, but just fucking stare at you. Yeah, okay. Oh, fuck. Oh, this will determine your fate.
Okay, I want to choose someone's seed, right? If you have the chance to pick your seed, would you?
I can literally hear it coming out of that.
I'll take the long seed. No, no.
Oh, no.
Wait, did she connect back? It's like no. Where is he? You die. How did I die?
Wait, what? We can pause the game. Wait, did I just disconnect? No, no, no. I paused the game. Oh, okay.
I think from what, because it's happened last time I played this, if we leave it, it'll save the progress.
Okay. We just have to wait for her to get back. All right, sounds good. If not, yeah.
You can continue playing. Go to square. Oh, no. Mercy, come back. I'm still here. What?
It's almost like I can hear her. Wait, what? Guys, can you guys hear her? Mercy, oh, mercy.
Did I disconnect? He disconnected from the game. Yes, but I'm still playing on my side.
What? You are? Yeah. We all like left the game. Yeah, but I'm still playing.
Oh, no. Let me go. But are you actively playing or are you?
We're on the mini game. We're on the mini game. I hope I win.
Tell me if I win. I'm just watching Mercy scream. How do I disconnect?
I'm watching us play balloon burst.
The two NPCs are winning. Let's go. Come on. Let's go, Poseidon.
Oh, oh, we won. Okay, we're back on turn eight.
This is your turn, Peach. Oh, okay. Let's see. Wait, how do we get out of here? But she's locked.
She's locked.
Mercy, if you can click the plush button, maybe, maybe, it's a star. It's one and a half.
Do I have to, like, quit out of it?
I think so. Oh, my God. I've never had your specific situation happen before.
Disconnected so badly. Anyways, I'm still playing the game. I want to win against the NPCs. Sorry.
Oh, sweet. I land on it again. Oh, damn. Get the fuck out of my way.
Please don't let me get a dice block. Oh, let's go.
Maybe I should, like, quit the game and join Mckin. Yeah. Can she? Perclapse.
Let me quit the game on my end. Okay. See if that'll do any.
It's black screen because I'm making sure that you, that, that some pies and snippets
and other people don't see what's going on if I accidentally dox myself or something. It's a safety
reason. Oh, I wonder if you, it says here, if you want to play the game with someone else,
press B to end your current session. But if we end the current session. We gotta start all over.
We might have to start over.
Is there less turns than 15? I'm sorry for somehow disconnecting.
It's okay. It's not your fault. It happens. It happens. It happens.
So, uh, how about them Dodgers, am I right?
Give me a second as I enter back in. I was like, what do you mean? It says I'm still going.
I'm still going. Okay, let me know. You see they had a fish girl up there.
She gave me a second. Yeah, I was like this weird ass fish girl and she was,
she was singing stuff. Is that like a kid's cartoon or something? Do I need to go back into
the ID that you guys gave me? The Megatron. The Megatron. Oh, flavor cake. Decepticons.
There's leches. That's my favorite cake. Oh, I love tres leches. Yeah. Okay. I was eating
air in the area, but I can't. There's no rooms available. So yeah, I love that. Oh, do I have
to re-invite you? Maybe. I wonder if there's a way I can re-invite. Some kind of Annie moves.
Megatron, Megatron wasn't the transformers were there.
Yeah, you better write that shit down. You might have to start over. I'm so sorry.
Can we do, can we do less turns? I think we can. Let me, let me actually. I don't have a life,
so we can do this all day, but I don't know about you guys. It's okay. I can do it all day.
I didn't have to go in like two hours, but we should be able to finish like one or two games in
two hours. Yeah. Yeah. So we're good. We're good. I'm so sorry. I was like, what the heck? It's okay.
Hey, does this work? No, it doesn't work. I don't know if it works. Please pick me up. I'm scared.
I don't, I don't have my microphone monitor in. I can't tell what that sounded like.
Well, I'm going to send advice right now. Yeah.
I apologize once again for my, no, no, you're okay.
Jason.
Shibamus Prime.
There comes a, no, I cannot do optimism. Not a man. Skimity, not skimity, skimity, toilet.
What does that mean? I don't know what skimity means. I don't know either. I just accept it.
People call me shibbity, toilet. Shibbity, toilet. Shibbity, toilet.
I'm gonna ban them tax and shibbity your toilet and riz. Yeah.
I'm not even paying attention. Sorry about that. Oh, I'm so sorry. I'm not looking at my screen.
I'm looking at the beautiful girls. Am I sins?
Hi there. How are you? I'm doing good. How are you? I shitted.
I have no idea how to respond.
Okay, we're ready. I'm in. I was just reading what Toadette was saying.
What did you say? Because Toadette was saying, hi, welcome in. How are you doing today? When
do you like enter the game? Uh huh. I shitted. I'm shitting and farting so hard and throwing up.
I threw up. I threw up. I had a good time. Yummy. Don't tire yourself out. Thanks, Toadette.
Huh? Okay, we're in. We're going down that hole.
Who's hole? You're hole. Prepare your ass. Okay.
We're at my strap. You know, I always stay strapped.
Um, you guys do want to do any extracurricular activities?
Hell yeah, brother. I shall reward myself with another cookie.
Okay, cookies. Yay, okay, we're back here again. We're back, baby. Yes, who's back? We didn't have
to ruin everything. I didn't ruin everything. Again, again.
Ten. Oh, oh. Oh, dang. Is this the same thing again? Yes. Damn. No. I can catch up.
Are you serious? The other two times they landed on the lucky space. This time you're like, no,
wrong. I'm so sorry. I hate it here.
I'm about to come in. The comeback starts now. I'm about to come on your back.
Oh, really? I'll make it happen somehow.
Where there's a wheel, there's a way. Mercy needs punishment. Mercy needs correction after the stream.
What? I need correction? Correction? For all your, uh, for all your little fucking strawberries.
That wasn't my strawberry this time. Oh, well, then you all get correction.
Plop, plop, plop, get corrected, get corrected.
That wasn't my strawberry this time. It doesn't matter. You're still getting, you're still getting.
I feel powerful.
Let's go. Once again. This is the comeback. Oh, yeah. Why is it getting hot in here? I don't know,
baby. Okay, now you can take my seed.
My money. My money. My seed.
You have a 25% chance of not the little one, the little one. I have a feeling.
I don't know. I kind of like this. This one is, it's, it's, it's, I like the fourth one.
Shiny. Actually, this one's nice too. It's cheap. Like a pumpkin.
Wait, if it's good, I'm going to be mad. But if it's bad, I'm going to be, oh.
It hurts from the day. You win it. Ha ha. Get corrected.
No.
Well, no, he's fourth. No, I have 14.
Oh, if you had the coins, then, because I think, I think Bowser's nice to you when you're in fourth.
Oh, nice. He gave you something at least. Yeah, he didn't like, wink anything from you.
Oh, he's going to all my coins. It's an ancient artifact. Scared.
I'm sorry. I encouraged that.
I was in last place already. I was like, I'm sorry. I liked it too. I suggested it.
Okay, what's this? Like that. Oh, I'm rocking my horse. Oh, you had to click L and R, like,
to like, in tandem with the spear. Like this?
You can't speed up too much.
I'm so bad at this one. What?
Oh, wait. Am I supposed to leave? What's wrong with the coins? Oh, you're supposed to.
Oh, you're supposed to stop. Kind of pace yourself, right? Yeah.
This is weird. I don't know how you avoid those little signs, though.
I think you wait for it to be a strawberry. But I hit it when it was a strawberry.
Isn't it a carrot? Oh, you hit it when it turned into a carrot is what.
Oh, yep. Is my rhythm on? Oh, when I hit it.
Oh, yes. I look like I'm just stimming.
This is just a stim session. I like it.
I'm going to try to learn how this works. Give me a second.
I'm rocking my horse. How am I in last place? Am I having to, like, go really?
I remember the first time my daddy got my first horse.
Yeah, don't hit it when it's blue.
I hate starting to cramp up. I know what I'm saying. My fingers hurt.
I don't really get it, but okay.
Damn, you Mario Party 3. I don't really get it, but okay.
It's okay. I might be dumb, but, you know.
No. Fuck. No.
It's been out a little bit.
I really do not believe this is the first time you've-
It really is. It's a gamer. I'm sorry.
It really is a gamer. I'm really, I'm really truthfully honest.
This is my first time. I get really excited about games. I just, I don't know.
She's just not that gamer girl. Do you guys want to play the actual one?
Okay, I don't know how to play this. Okay.
Don't want to exhaust your carrots.
I am not a gamer, probably.
I'm the god of horses, yet I can't do a good horse impression.
Okay.
What the heck?
Why am I stuck? I'm pressing the buttons.
What the hell? Why am I stuck?
This is unfair! This is shit!
What the heck?
Oh no!
Why am I stuck?
Damn it.
Fuck!
I was on Apollo's ass.
Oh no!
Mercy!
I don't know why!
Oh no.
How the heck?
I'm so far behind. What the hell? Like, I was like, why is some of the buttons working?
Oh no!
I was trying to go in a rhythm. I was like one, two, one, two.
I wasn't happening to do that, but I have no sense of rhythm.
I just didn't want to go.
Oh damn, you have saved me.
I'm so far.
I have the worst luck, Senpai.
Like, actually the worst luck ever.
Your turn, Waluigi.
Please.
No, I wanted one of those things.
I want a strawberry.
What?
That was a hiccup, sorry.
Oh wait, do I go down the slide?
No, I don't!
I wanted to go down the slide.
The cost of your next star is cut in half.
That sounds so good.
Only I had money!
You got three coins? You're getting up there in the world.
Let me out of here.
Oh no!
Why are you zooming?
You don't have a dove!
She was sprinting.
No!
Oh no.
I didn't!
It's time.
Later, skater.
Let's get ready to rumble!
What is this?
Hold A to move forward.
What?
Oh, are we...
Oh my god, they hate me.
I used to do ice skating too.
What the hell?
Okay, I kind of get it.
I like skating.
Sort of.
There's a skater boy.
I got the gist.
I think I understand.
This was not...
Look at Apollo fucking zooming around.
Do you see that?
My controller is not working?
I have a strat.
Oh no!
Is your controller not working?
Mine just stopped.
Mine just stopped all of a sudden.
I think it's just being weird.
No, I think it's because you finished the five laps.
I didn't finish the five laps.
I just went around like twice.
Strat. Strat. Strat.
Up the inside.
It's not working.
Is that the strat in real ice skating?
Yeah, 100%.
You just kick off one foot profusely.
Alright, that strat's not working.
Focus, focus, focus.
Yes!
I have no idea what I'm doing.
My strat didn't work, guys.
We did our best.
Fuck, I'm still in last.
But you're almost there.
You're almost ready to buy a star.
Wow, Apollo literally needs to roll.
I'm sorry.
You just somehow roll a zero.
Do I need it?
Cannibal.
Madam is simply an innovator.
I'll just have it.
Thank you, Harley.
Yay!
Silence is deafening.
You're all just quietly seething.
I'm so sorry.
I'm locked in.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Was the triple-dice always there?
Yeah, I have triple-dice.
What's the mushroom?
I don't know what the mushroom does.
I think one of the people stomps them.
Or does it make you go faster?
This is only the beginning.
Hopefully I can start stealing.
No!
I want to steal.
I want to commit crimes.
I want to...
You have 40 coins!
I'm sorry!
I swear.
I never got the item because it never saved.
Damn it.
Damn, it's a killer out here.
Are you making freaking cheese meat?
At least you get a star!
That's true.
I think that's a granted.
I do have enough money.
Hi honey.
Stop!
I can't...
Can you do it again?
We're like...
Good...
Good girl, good boy.
Praise is like my weakness.
Oh, you're such a good girl.
Nice.
Oh god, I'm wet.
Do you ever have to wash your hair?
Yeah, every now and then.
How does that work?
Do you skim it?
Does it jump into a pool and come back out fresh?
You got to get the pH balance right.
Just as carefully as you're coochie.
Son of a bitch!
If you didn't know, Chatters,
vaginas are acidic and they have their special pH balance.
Come on, you know.
Son of a bitch!
Wait, now Mercy, this is karma?
What you did to Sheepie?
She said it.
This is karma.
I've been taking elses the entire time!
Let me have one steel!
What is this?
Oh, it's this one.
Whoever's in the front steers and the other one flaps the wings.
Okay, then flap the wings.
Sorry, I thought I was in the front.
I'm flapping the wings.
I'm trying to steer it so hard.
Girlie Pop, I don't know if we're winning this one.
It's okay, I'm sorry.
My wing flaps are bad.
Oh, what the heck?
I didn't look so much farther away than it actually did.
Start flapping your ears.
Maybe we'll start flapping.
Okay, I think I get it, sort of.
I'm being shot at.
They're cheating.
What do you mean we're cheating?
They have hacks, bro.
They have hacks, that's all I'm gonna say.
Hey, hey, hey, don't be a sore loser.
What? Why am I going?
Am I not?
Am I the one flapping the wings?
Am I not flapping karma?
I'm trying!
I don't know why it's low.
You think I should go down?
Can you...
Be gentle.
Is this not fast enough?
I can't handle this.
Okay, we're actually in the front.
I feel like I'm the reason why this is not working.
You're flapping so fast, the wings aren't even fucking moving.
My thumb is cramping.
What the fuck?
I'm like, oh my god.
Okay, I think I get it.
Start, start, whatever.
I can't get it here.
It is what it is.
I'm gonna try my best.
I'm sorry, the polo.
It's okay.
Yeah, get the fuck out.
Move, bitch.
Get out the way.
I'm flapping as hard as I can.
Flip, flip.
I'm flapping.
Why did we get it twice?
I'm so upset.
I'm flapping as fast as I can.
I don't think we can.
It's like a sheebie.
No.
Okay, it's fine.
What?
We don't do it.
I'm so sorry.
Lesson learned.
Don't let sheebie or me drive a car.
I did almost get into a car accident today.
Oh no.
It wasn't my fault.
I'm not a bad driver.
I'm a great driver.
I believe you.
It's just...
Polo is such a gamer.
Wait, we're finished?
No, we're half.
We're half.
I was like, what?
This is impossible.
Am I in fourth?
How are you in fourth?
Don't you have more?
I'm actually going to cry.
Burp cry.
Oh no.
No, you're fine.
Five out of ten.
Okay, thank you for the nine out of ten rating.
Appreciate you.
Seven.
Sorry.
Let's hear a prediction
from one of our board cores.
Okay.
Seems like Mario is the best chance.
Probably. Let's go with that.
I feel like that's a lie.
Watch Mario.
Watch Marcy win.
What's a plunder, Sam?
Why don't I get it?
I'm in fourth, man.
Oh yeah, I can feel it.
Are you serious?
Stay away from me right now.
Oh, now the blue spaces give double now.
And you also lose double.
Damn.
I am fighting whomever shares my space.
I love being a thief.
Oh no.
We pretty much all have items.
Except for me.
I don't have any items.
Okay, it's okay.
If you get one, one, one.
What?
Oh my god.
I don't believe her.
That's 17 stars to get.
Watch her get the right seed.
No.
Please don't pick the right one.
It's my life.
My bestie for charity.
Oh my God.
Are you serious?
Lexie, not the bad.
What the heck is this?
I don't know what is going on.
I emoted before it.
I didn't even do it before.
It did it by itself.
I don't know what's going on.
I'm crying.
What the hell?
How could this happen to me?
I made my...
You could have gotten a large one.
That's what I was saying.
I could, but I didn't like my coins.
Oh my God.
It's like my wife's bestie.
You have two stars.
I don't need any more coins.
I like collecting the stars.
What the heck?
Give me your star.
I'm going to get your star.
I'm just going to...
That's all I got to say.
At least I can buy a fucking star.
Now you're in second place.
Yeah!
You're going to be in second place now.
You're in second place now. Congratulations!
Hey, Lisa.
I think it's to steal stars.
Or I would lose my mind.
Oh God.
I don't want to buy anything.
Because the Mercy is just going to steal it.
I love stealing.
Oh, true.
I'm not even buying anything.
Now we're fighting.
I need to fight Mercy!
Oh, shit!
Oh, you guys can pick how many coins to win.
I'm only going to do three.
Well, I can only wage you five.
I'll wage you all my coins.
Okay.
Wait, what did I click?
I accidentally clicked the sticker thing.
Sister versus sister.
Oh, I got to pick.
Ah!
Damn!
We just start punching each other?
What's happening?
What's this?
What is this?
Well, that looks easy.
Never mind.
Don't get too close. Stay back.
What the fuck?
What is that?
Stay back.
How am I supposed to get through this?
Up and down, up and down.
I can't go up and down.
I'm not used to it.
Oh my God.
You're going to go slow.
Okay.
I have to go fast and hard.
Thank you for training.
Imagine somebody who's just listening
watching what the fuck is going on.
He's in!
I'm going too rough.
I got to be gentle.
I like it rough, fast, hard.
We're doing it.
No questions.
I don't care if I hurt myself.
I'm plunging ahead.
What the hell?
All right.
I'm ready.
I'm not ready. What the hell?
You got this?
No, I don't.
Why is my hitbox so large?
Fuck.
Okay.
I get it, but this is going to be hell.
Why do I got to swim through space?
I can't even breathe.
I don't like swimming.
I might swim like Eldritch MZ.
Hello, Hades.
I love you.
Thank you so much for the raid, honey.
Hi, Hades.
I like how we both talk about the same thing.
Balls in front of my face.
That's all I know.
Why are you doing the same exact thing?
Hello, hello.
Hi, Hades.
Hades is the same shit.
Please, I hope your stream was very lovely.
I love this minigame.
I love this. This is very chaotic.
It's very fun.
No, she's beating me.
Damn, she's going hard.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Oh, no.
I don't want to win. No.
Oh, my God.
This is great.
Let me in.
I don't want to win.
No.
Oh, my God.
Damn, mercy.
Too many balls hit on her face.
Damn.
I'll be taking the coins back
that you took from me.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, miss.
I love you, mercy.
I love you so much, mercy.
I'm so sorry. I just lost six of the coins,
so it doesn't matter.
Let's go.
Let's go. Let's go.
Oh, is it my turn?
Okay, it's my, wait, hold up.
You know what, wait.
Let me see.
Wait, now the snippets,
now the senpais are going to come for me.
No, they won't.
No, they won't. I will, though.
I'll be like, I'm used to this.
I'll have you in my cage.
I fell asleep to your ass.
Oh, my compliment.
Even though I was shaking the bars and stuff.
Yeah, I literally knocked out.
I was like, this is comfy.
Let's go.
Okay.
Which seed?
You know what? Oh.
Oh.
Pick your seed.
Okay.
So you have to give a
kind of a big one.
Or a little one.
That one looks like my breast.
So I'm going to.
Ayo.
Welcome.
Poggers.
Oh, so that is good.
Oh, I thought it was bad.
I don't get to see daddy.
I'm so sad.
Dude.
I wanted to see that.
Welcome to the Chance Time Space.
Make your dream come true.
Stars and points will move from player to player.
Exactly.
Keep in mind.
You can lose your star to one of us, though.
No.
Okay, let's go.
Hi, honey.
Oh.
No.
Give Kona points.
Two.
Mercy.
Pay up.
Damn.
Damn it.
I wish it were me.
Yeah.
No.
I'm back down to the last Monday.
Monday.
Mommy, mommy, mommy.
No.
It's one of your guys's turn with Bowser now.
Wait, never mind.
I have to use the last one because I'm going to end up with Bowsy Boo anyways.
Mystical.
You have a 50-50 chance.
You do.
Follow your heart.
Damn.
The green one looks cute.
Catch a tiger by the toe.
If he hollers, let him go.
Oh, god. I didn't notice freaking bow on the top left.
Yeah, you like my pregnant bow?
She's so hot.
Pregnant bow?
Yeah.
Throw me to the wolves and I'll come back pregnant.
Damn.
I think I might have a pregnancy.
What?
Oh, shit.
Elaborate, please.
I don't know.
Breeding kink?
Do you want to be bred?
Yes, I do.
I have a breeding kink.
Not all my mods joining in.
I just got in here.
Honestly, I'm going to have to agree on that.
Thank you.
When I ran into this video
where the girl was pregnant,
I was like, wait, I kind of like...
Why do I...
Maybe for me, not the preynib,
but like the breeding part, you know?
Breeding is kind of wholesome.
Yeah.
I like breeding my little boy sluts.
Wait!
My hair knows.
I know where to save you.
Pregnant bow.
Oh, it's this one.
Oh, it's me and Mercy this time.
Sorry, I'm the worst.
Oh!
Oh, okay. I have Apollo on my team.
We got this.
We have to work together.
I'm trying.
We got this, Apollo.
Whee!
Fact!
Oh!
I'm behind the road.
Okay, we go left.
I think we should slow down at like the hard turn.
Right?
Fast, fast, fast.
I'm going to step on the gas.
How do you accelerate in a bobsled?
I don't know.
Ah!
Why are we against the wall?
You know what? I'm ready.
All right, I'm ready.
Okay.
I'm ready then.
I didn't know we could fall.
No, it's okay. It's fine.
It's okay.
We got this. We fall off.
I hope that doesn't make us auto lose.
Okay.
We're making a left turn.
Oh my god, they're on our booty cheeks.
Give me that, buddy.
Oh, fuck.
It's fine.
Let's go!
Yeah!
I think it's me.
I'm so sorry.
No, you're fine.
Wait, we're doing this.
Sort of. We're doing it. We're doing it, Marcy.
We're doing it.
No, you're not.
Dad, I swear I could drive a car.
I have my license.
Oh, no, we're good.
Stay close to the wall.
We're good. We're good.
We're good.
My thumb hurts so bad.
Where the fuck did they go?
Damn!
We did it!
Damn it.
Oh my god.
I think it's me. I think I'm the common link.
I apologize.
I don't know how to do this.
We're still at the bottom.
I didn't even know what it was doing.
I'm just pressing the button.
Also, it's not you.
I think...
They're just gamers, to be honest.
Oh, are you saying I'm not a gamer?
They're just gamers.
We're just gamers?
You're like the gamer.
And I'm like...
I'm not the gamer.
Wait, aren't you? You play souls like.
That doesn't mean I'm a gamer.
I'm not good at them.
That makes you like...
Gamer, gamer, you know?
You can ask my hair members.
They know I'm shit at the game.
No, harems! Tell! Tell!
I'm Paolo right now.
She is as great at games.
I'm pretty sure.
I don't even want to talk about my Elden Ring gameplay.
I couldn't even get to the boss
because I was just like, I'm just so shit at this game.
So let me just level up.
I'm going to take my four coins.
Oh, come on.
Everyone says you're just being modest.
Being modest?
Pick whatever your heart tells you to pick.
Do I tap on it? How the heck do I...
How the heck do I...
Oh, I want this one.
Which one is it?
Looks like it's getting sucked into a booty hole.
Booty, booty, booty, booty.
I love that song.
I don't have any money, Bowser.
What are you going to do?
Booty, booty, booty, booty.
Again?!
Damn.
Sweet.
We have to get to the jewel
because you don't have any money.
Wow!
I don't have any money, so we can't duel.
She broke.
I can't.
No, so close.
Let's go.
It's my turn.
Uh-oh.
These chocolates look so good.
I'm so hungry for sweets now.
Can you get that Muppet off screen?
It's going to make me act up.
No.
I'm dead.
The Muppet stays on.
The Muppet watches.
I need art of me
doing chat while having my Muppet
in one hand, but it's a double team.
You stare into the Muppet
and say apps.
I don't know if you can handle it.
I don't think I can, to be honest.
No!
Don't rob me!
Walk away!
I've been robbed.
I'm so sorry.
No, you're not!
I'm sorry!
Just a little.
This happened to me.
If you're not, it's Muppet.
You're wrong.
Thank you, Serenity.
She says, and that's sorry at all.
Okay, maybe a little.
Okay.
19 coins!
My coins!
Son of a bitch!
Hmm.
Oh, you have to pick an item to get rid of.
That works out.
He basically just got nothing.
He just got nothing.
Uh-oh!
Oh, no! This could change it all!
No!
When I steered us to victory.
If I give my stars to anyone,
I'm crying.
I'm going to cry.
I'm shibbing my pants right now.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
Again?
Okay, that's not bad.
That's not bad.
It's fine.
Like an awkwardly look at each other.
I'm sorry.
I'm a saudi.
Pain.
That was right.
Pain day.
What does that mean?
Like Texas Apocalypse.
Open a box?
What's this mean?
I thought it meant open a bomb.
No.
Oh.
Oh, you have to remember what's in the boxes.
Oh!
What the hell is that?
I'm getting punched.
Am I getting coins?
Oh, try to open boxes with coins in them.
Okay.
I got it.
Okay, I kind of get it.
This is kind of hard.
Yeah, I can't remember.
I can't remember which box is which.
It's memory.
I don't have good memory.
That's the thing!
I thought it was a chef hat in there.
I don't have any of them.
I wonder what the sac of money does.
A pollo?
Oh.
I just blew myself off.
I thought you were saying you just blew yourself off.
This is a terrible airport.
I'm gonna die.
Oh.
No, for sure not that one.
Shit.
Oh.
No!
My memory!
I was trying so hard to remember.
I'm glad my memory is still good.
Sort of.
My memory is terrible.
My goldfish brain couldn't be bought.
I'm still in fourth. Dang it.
So mercy.
My life is in half.
There's also the other stars.
There's also the other stars at the end.
The bonus stars.
What's your bonus stars?
I need my one star!
Come on!
What?
I'm sorry.
There's no one fucking way!
There's no one!
I hate you.
I'm sorry.
Why is Donkey Kong
just like
chocolatey cheeked up over there?
I know.
Oh, great.
Now I get to talk to Bowser.
Maybe he'll show pity on you.
But are you sorry?
I mean, I'm sorry.
No, we're not compatible.
We're two doms.
So it's not gonna work out between us.
We're battling for dominance.
I could kind of hunt.
But I'm a swish.
I'm not very dominant.
Praise the sun.
Great. I have four coins.
You guys got to start praying
for your Kohai's right now.
Why did you have to rob me like this, bro?
Alright.
This is it.
Look out, she's...
You know what?
This is...
It's so bad.
Alright!
We pray every day.
Oh, your community is still wholesome.
They're so kind.
Look at you.
They're praying for you.
Yeah, you give her energy.
I don't know if that was bad or good.
Wait!
It was bad!
Yeah, sorry. Sorry, Sheebie.
Oh, I was so close.
Now I'm gonna be in third.
You're not a star.
I might...
Let's go!
I'm not even emoting.
It just doesn't buy itself.
It's not for me to pull out a fight.
Oh, shit.
Why is it always Jen against their own Jen?
How many are we waiting?
I'm down away, you're dead.
Okay, sure.
Oh, god.
Ten coins!
What?
It's time to tool.
It's time to...
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm scared.
Let's get ready to rumble!
What do I do?
What are we doing?
Oh, god.
I'm so nervous.
Is this Mario?
Is this Mario Kart or something?
Mario Hover.
Oh, I see.
I was looking at your character.
I was like, why is it moving?
You do look almost the same.
Yeah, I mean, you do look almost the same.
Remember, you're blue.
You know, like...
Yeah, you're blue.
You don't want to hit the electricity.
They're excited.
Water conducts electricity, you're right.
Oh, no.
You want to go through the opening that isn't...
Yeah, like that.
Okay, the controls feel weird.
Ah, no!
You did it, though.
Okay, I get it. I get it.
I think I get it, too.
You can do it. You can do it.
I want to commentate.
Stop.
Okay, so...
Starting off strong.
We have both girls on the right side coming through the hole.
They are neck-and-neck, folks.
Wow, they are neck-and-neck.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Wait, who got first?
I don't know.
Ha ha ha!
We don't look the same.
Let's go!
The controls for that are so weird.
I'm like, I can't do it.
That looked weird.
That looked hard.
When I was younger, I wanted to be a CS go commentator.
How young am I?
I can't go into the electricity.
Can you blame me? I like to electrify myself.
Wait, hold on. Maybe I'll use an animal.
It's electric.
Do you like getting shot?
Yes.
Here we go!
I have a taser.
I have a shock collar.
I also have a shock collar.
Oh my god, that's right.
We can't use it.
It's Twitch TOS.
What about YouTube?
Please, baby girl.
I got you.
Give me a star, finally!
I'm going to be like Harley Quinn.
Ha ha ha ha!
Electrifying.
Money, give me money again.
I just walked out of my bedroom.
What the fuck are you doing?
I moved me with you.
Oh my gosh, I almost read that as Bowser's big breast.
Ha ha ha ha!
You suck on Bowser's titty.
Yeah.
Oh, this is like a racing one.
Okay, this is fun.
Oh shit.
Oh, you can spin out?
I don't understand how that works.
Oh my god, I got thrown out.
I got kicked out.
Of the game?
No, they're gone.
They swooned me over, but yeah.
Okay, I'm dead.
So try four naps to watch your speed.
If you run too fast around the curbs,
we'll make you spin out to be careful.
Oh, okay, okay, I get it.
How do I want to spin off of the map?
That sounds like fun.
Oh, I get it.
Okay, I think I get it.
I get it.
Okay, I think I get it, but I'm not going to be great at it.
We neither.
Apologies.
Oh, fair enough.
I'm trying.
I'm going to try my best.
Hello, thank you so much for following, honey.
Can you say that again?
Well, like, with Mercy instead of Honey?
Oh, uh,
I believe so.
I think, I think maybe not.
I don't think I can.
Can you?
No.
Oh, I'm doing it.
I'm doing it.
I still don't get this.
Yeah!
I was so close.
See, look, I can drive chat.
I swear I have my license.
I was so close.
We did all dial in.
We're focused.
We're locked in, baby girl.
I can't believe I came in fourth.
Who's fourth?
Mercy, I'm reaching through the screen
and I'm just grabbing you by the throat.
I'm really, I'm choking your model.
I'm reaching at my screen right now.
Just...
I love your laugh so much.
Her evil little laugh.
Yeah, she does like it.
I should know better.
She likes being choked.
She'll just laugh hilariously
while she's being choked.
Oh God.
Excuse me, may I please be choked too?
Of course, sweetheart.
Oh my God.
Thank you.
Slide back on the bed.
Oh, shit.
Oh my God.
And squeeze ever so tight.
Sorry, sorry. The Patreon voice came out.
I apologize.
Please, please continue.
Please continue.
Make the one that looks like my boob again.
The boobies.
Yeah!
Oh my God.
It literally shaped like my perky ass boobies.
So about those...
Those boobies?
Yes.
They look so heavy.
Is that for you?
Can I have one and then Mercy has the other?
Yes.
Hell yeah.
They hurt, they hurt. I need help.
I need assistance.
If only there were two beautiful girls
who are a bunny and have a suit.
He's gonna help me.
Oh no.
What you cut out.
I will live.
There is, there baby.
What are you buying?
What are you selling?
My body.
You know, I run a brothel.
I think you would make a great addition.
It's called Wonderland.
We're having interviews this Sunday.
I don't know if you're free.
Damn, I'm always free for you.
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna cry. Please don't.
No.
Oh yeah, I'm safe.
Yay, good for you, Mercy.
Oh yeah.
Oh no, it's me and Mercy's time to fight.
It's time to...
For fuck's sake.
How many, how many, how many you want to...
I only want to...
What if they kiss?
Never mind. I said one.
One...
One coin?
I'm a coward.
Come on, Mercy. Go hard or go home.
I'm a coward. I'm a coward.
You could have pulled in a second with this one.
I'm sorry.
I can't like, double tap.
That was my badge.
What the heck is this?
Man, I wish I had this.
That would be gorgeous.
Fuck!
Shit.
Oh, this is the worst.
This is the worst. I hate jumping.
Rump.
Hickory dickory, doc.
Mario went up the jump.
The clocks.
Mercy had to pee.
Mercy!
I could have to pee.
Oh my god, you are not real.
You are not real.
Just follow.
I hate jumping.
Picks Mario.
Listen.
He has my needle.
I'm gonna use your restroom.
I'm gonna get this.
Probably.
Okay, I think I can do it.
I'm in hell.
Wait, I went forward.
It goes backwards and forwards.
Mercy!
At least he only wagered one.
He immediately dies.
Look at Mario's face. It's such a mood.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
How did we punch at the air?
It's okay. You got 20 coins.
It's fine. You got more coins than I did.
Oh my god.
What the heck is this?
Cheep cheep.
Are we grabbing cheep cheeps?
Oh, never mind.
We are avoiding.
Wait, what?
How are we supposed to...
Oh, dive.
How do you dive?
Wait, how do you do this again?
You have to hold down the joystick.
Pull it down.
Did you guys hear my toilet?
What?
Did you wash?
Wait, were you peeing?
Yeah, I went to go pee.
You were peeing on Mike?
No.
Well, she probably muted her stream but didn't mute her.
Okay, I'm sorry. I don't get this.
How do I dive?
You pull the joystick down.
Okay, like right in front of it?
Yeah.
Like towards you.
Fuck!
Oh.
Yeah.
Like towards you.
Fuck!
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no.
Wow, Pixelmia, thank you for the rain.
Jesus.
Oh my god.
Hold down while mashing A.
Oh, okay.
I feel like I almost got it but at the same time I don't.
I don't got it.
I'm gonna just die.
Poseidon's winning this one.
This is the water.
This is the water buff.
I'm not even paying attention in the beginning
and I keep getting sucked in.
Would you like to start?
Wait, I think I got it.
You gotta time the dives though.
Yeah.
I think I got it.
You wanna mash right at the beginning
or you're gonna get sucked in?
Oh, whoops, I didn't mean to skip.
No mercy!
Oh, no.
It's over now.
Oh, they're moving.
No!
Oh, you all won!
We lose.
My favorite.
Wow, Luigi, eat my titties.
I'm gonna cry.
Wow, it made such a difference.
What's that?
This is the final turn.
We're gonna get bonus stars.
The final stretch.
Damn, she's zooming.
Peach is like, I got places to be.
I don't have any items.
I have a cursed dice block.
What do you expect me to do with that chat?
I think you can give it to someone else.
Look.
I'm giving it to Apollo.
Oh, my God!
I'm shitting me right now.
Oh, God, to see Bowser!
What the fuck?
But I wanna see Bowser.
No!
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God, all three of them are killing me.
This is gonna be fun to watch.
Oh, you can choose who you wanna fight.
Choose.
Damn, I wish I was there.
No!
Just feel like bullying me now!
Will you accept this, Rose?
I'm on that vibe.
It's time to cast.
It's time for my voice casting.
I'm ready.
Stop.
Mercy has just been getting bullied.
This whole time.
Wait for all your coins, you fool.
Okay, I'm gonna go pee guys while
you guys do this.
I'll be back.
Go piss, girl.
God!
Wow!
It's okay.
It's fun.
Oh, yeah.
I love Bowser.
Oh.
What's this?
It's a spin doctor.
I don't know where I'm going.
Yeah, where's the ending pose?
How am I supposed to cast this?
Oh.
Oh, dang it.
Where's the way?
I have no idea.
I think it's in the top right corner.
Yeah, it is.
This is hard.
Okay, I was just trying to find
the exit then.
And there's the ending!
Let's get ready to spin!
Oh, with this one!
I hate this one.
This one stresses me out.
And they are off.
Mercy immediately jumping in.
So is Apollo. Both going straight,
waiting, turning.
They're matching each other's speed.
Neither one is ahead.
Uh-oh.
Apollo pulls ahead.
Mercy taking it right.
Oh, shit.
They realize that they're both trapped in this area.
They need to go in a different direction.
Oh, shit.
And then they're just spinning in circles.
Mercy is going backwards.
And so is Apollo.
They're both confusedly
getting into the little spinning thing.
Apollo pulls up straight.
So...
Oh, no!
Apollo misses. Mercy manages to get in.
She is pulling ahead, folks.
She is zooming through very close to the goal.
Apollo not so close behind.
Oh, my God.
Oh, shit.
Then I was like,
we need a millisecond.
The crowd goes wild.
Oh, my God.
That really was a millisecond.
Can we get a replay of that?
I know. We need a replay.
I'm watching them back on, like,
fucking Vaughn.
Holy shit.
I know the silence from both of you.
They're all locked in.
Look at that. They prayed.
They prayed so hard.
They got it!
I'm sorry.
I'm so done!
I'm so...
I'm sorry.
I hate it here.
This is my final turn.
31!
Hold up.
Who is...
Is anybody close?
Okay.
Everybody's on the shame block.
So, you know what?
I will take my chances.
Wow, it literally was like a millisecond.
Oh, shit.
I took my chances, okay?
I was really hoping
it was going to land on Stevie.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Wait, me and him are alone.
Daddy?
Oh, okay.
I'll sit in the chair for this.
Stay.
We're watching you guys.
It's a bench.
Oh, God.
We'll receive 1,000 coins.
Holy fuck!
What?
1,000 coins!
No pecking way.
Did he just fucking rock?
What happened here?
What the fuck?
I said I'm not giving you shit.
Wait, he didn't even give me 1,000 coins!
He said a fucking scam!
What the heck?
He's like, don't mention it.
Runs away.
Daddy ain't sugaring right now.
Damn, I thought he was...
Yeah, I thought he was going to blend you some sugar.
Apparently not.
Oh, no.
I'm so sad.
I thought you were going to get 1,000 coins!
I thought so, too.
I was so excited.
This is not going to get me stars,
but at least I'll have the most coins.
I'm so sad.
I'm so sorry that he just...
Oh, God.
At least we're not going around again.
Do a large.
Just kidding. Don't do that.
At this point, it's the last turn.
Yeah.
What if she spent her coins?
Then she ends up in third.
Mercy, why did you do that?
I might just cry.
Mercy, I told you not to!
Oh, sorry. The voice is one.
The voice is one.
No.
See, you would have been second.
Wait, what?
It's okay. We have bonus coins.
The voice in my head won.
I just wanted the big one.
It's very interesting.
Where is it going?
I'm sorry. I'm stupid.
I can't.
What is this?
What?
Am I... Oh, I'm steering.
I think.
No, I think we're both steering.
Does it even matter anymore?
There's a shack.
Swiggity-swooty.
Who's throwing stuff?
The hammer guy is also still throwing stuff.
I kind of get it.
Yeah!
I think I got it.
Kind of.
Oh, my God. Let's roll.
Sorry.
You're good.
There was such a gamer move,
and then watch Mercy pull in first.
Oh, my cat is...
Where are we going?
What?
Get the shack.
You landed right on them.
I know.
Oh, no.
Come on.
We got to get it.
We're going to get it.
No, I'm so sorry.
It's me.
We both steering.
I blame my cat.
My cat, Fia, she distracted me.
It's okay.
I will...
I will forgive.
I'm sorry. She be cat debuff.
Yeah.
All right.
Now who will win at all?
I can't talk.
The first focus is...
That is not me.
I didn't have any.
I think I'll be Mercy.
Here.
Did I get one for coming in fourth?
I'm a star.
I love that movie.
I still have yet to launch it.
Oh, you passed you.
I'm the slowpoke.
Thanks.
Hey, you can win.
I'm really going to be...
Our final announcement.
Nothing.
And the winner is...
I got fatted.
We saw that coming from like 20 miles away.
I thought with the bonus stars, you would have a chance, but...
I'm so sad.
Yeah, the super star.
I'm the winner.
Oh, my God.
The person who's never played before.
I'm not playing.
It's Mercy being off the bed.
You're not needed.
Oh, Mercy.
Can I come in fourth?
Mercy, why did you buy the plant?
The voice is one.
This is Peach's map.
She had it off already.
Can you believe that effort?
You got a super.
Thank you for the 10 super.
Okay, Kola, you're a winner in our hearts.
Thank you.
I love you. You did so well.
Yeah.
It's okay.
That's all effort.
In the arms of an angel.
Oh, man.
If I had seven more coins, if only Bowser paid me...
I had so much fucking coins though.
You would have won.
You got the thousand coins.
Oh, my God.
I came out of those coins.
That was very fun.
Yes indeed.
That was fun.
Mario Party.
Can I check?
I have to go.
Yes, that is fine.
Please go.
I leveled up in Mario Party.
I'm 23 now.
This was so fun.
That was fun.
I would love to do this again.
But drunk.
That would be so funny.
I am so up for that.
I love you too, actually.
We'll plan that man next time.
Hell yeah.
Drunk Mario Kart.
The rage quid eye driver.
The drunk driving.
Don't do drunk driving, guys.
No, we're not endorsing that.
No, not at all.
Only in Mario Kart.
Only in Minecraft.
Thank you so much for joining us.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
See y'all later.
Thanks for having us, Smithos girls.
You guys were an absolute pleasure.
Can't wait to hang out with you guys again.
Yes, for sure.
Goodbye.
Bye.
And now it's just us.
Oh.
Do you want me to leave
so you can talk to you?
I can't talk to them.
You can also talk to them if you want.
Yay, I'll chat with them.
Go to just chatting.
Let me see if it works.
Get rid of my Muppet.
It should be gone.
Yeah, now that we're in just chatting.
Hold on.
Now that we're in just chatting.
Woohoo.
Let me just exit out of my gamey.
You're leaning back.
That's all.
No shibby audio?
What the heck?
Give me a second.
There we go.
I don't exist anymore.
Hi.
Can you hear her now?
She's back.
Oh my gosh, your hair is so big.
I'm so sorry.
I meant to release.
I'm taking off my limiter.
Let me just...
Yes.
Do you want me to put it back on?
I'll put it back on.
Hold on, I got you.
Mine.
Give me bunny ears.
Oh my gosh, I have to put these back.
My Joy-Con's back.
Wait, I don't know if people...
Okay, they can't see it.
Wait, are you going to give me bunny ears?
Yup.
Oh dear.
Hoins.
They're technically devil hordes.
That's the way you get it.
Let me throw my hands away.
Let me put my...
Perfect.
This will work out.
Let me...
Oh fuck.
Now I was gone.
I'm trying to bring myself lower,
but it's not working.
It's okay.
I locked my model, there we go.
Hi.
I should be like lower,
because I'm shorter.
Let me move myself up.
I'm getting cozy.
My scissors are too big.
My hair is coming out from underneath the blanket.
Okay, I'll join you in blanket-ness.
Yeah, are we gonna...
I feel like we're having a sleepover.
Should we tell stories?
Oh yeah, we should tell stories.
Oh my gosh, I had so much fun with the...
There we go.
We look so cute.
Oh my gosh.
I like how your scissors are poking out.
Probably gonna be poking out.
Hanging out with Mythos was so fun.
I know, right? I'm so glad they invited us
for a collab.
That was really fun, even though I like lost so many times.
Hey, I came in...
Oh wait, no, you came in fourth.
You forget about my last...
The last second...
Oh, we only had it five.
I'm playing.
I'm laughing so hard my cheeks hurt.
Oh my god.
Yes, they're all very cute girls.
Those girls are really fun, yeah.
They're right up our alley too.
We have such similar personalities.
They have the same jokes.
Yeah, I'm like...
I feel like...
I feel like if we were ever
in a company together, it would just make sense.
I honestly said
they would fit in via law.
I think they suit Mythos
also very well. Oh yeah, 100%.
What?
I just want to steal them for a second, Jen.
My eyebrows?
Yeah, what is happening there?
What's going on?
It's wiggling.
Then you blink.
That's so weird.
I realize me and you haven't collabed one-on-one.
Oh yeah, we haven't.
Yeah, I've only done it with Azura.
I have to make sure I collab
with my own gen mates one-on-one.
I don't think I've actually
collabed with any of my gen mates
except for Strani
because that was one of the earlier ones.
Yeah, and I did Azura.
What game?
We played Fall Guys.
What would you guys want to watch
me and
Mercy play?
Bye Poseidon, it was so fun playing.
Poseidon, hold on.
Give her the hot girl wrench.
How can I give her the hot girl wrench?
Why am I bad at this?
Three dots and then make more.
I can't do it.
Hold on, let me do it.
I'm a standard moderator.
I'm so bad at this.
I went in and added
like the VNU girls.
Manually.
I did too.
For some of the girls.
Add as moderator.
Standard moderator.
Get wrenched, get wrenched, get wrenched, get wrenched.
Hot girls get wrenched.
Either of you played a way out,
I have played a way out.
Like long, long, long ago.
Atix too would probably make her motion sick
because it's made me motion sick before.
I played that too, but
very slowly because of my motion sickness.
Yeah.
I call a puzzle bang.
Puzzle bang? Excuse me?
Puzzle what?
Puzzle game would be good too
is what I was going to say.
I was like bang.
Sorry Freudian slip. Thank you so much Minish for the 10.
Poggers?
Poggers.
Gifted 10.
Absolute beast.
Let's go. Thank you.
Go off.
Puzzle bang. I'm terrible at puzzles.
Porto too would make me cry as well.
Poseidon cost night.
Poseidon.
She got gifted a membership.
Let's go.
What the heck Poseidon?
You're so lucky.
Senpai.
You get
the hot girl ring.
You got a standing member.
A tear.
Senpai.
I'll let you vote.
Thank you Yon.
I'm Epi.
Yeah Epi.
Senpai.
It's a little bit Epi.
It's a game that we both just be
adorably failure at.
That's every game.
That's a good point.
That's every game for me.
The bomb diffusing game.
I can't read.
I keep talking and nobody explodes to be hilarious.
Cuphead?
We would both be raging so hard if we played Cuphead.
I think Cuphead we would cry.
Yeah.
Simulator?
We have to finish a campaign first.
Yeah.
I have to do that.
Bye Poseidon.
Thank you for joining us.
Thank you for the invite.
I love you.
We would be stuck on the same level
for like
three hours.
That's so true.
I never beat Cuphead.
I think I got all the way to Marina
or whatever the octopus lady was
and I just gave up.
I love
the octopus lady.
She looks pretty.
Yeah. I love the designs of the bosses
in the game are really cool.
Super Bunny Man.
Yes.
I played Super Bunny Man
with Toma.
It's so funny.
It's like little platforming.
You just have to clear levels
but there's like really funny physics
and we have to like grab each other
and like flip each other
and we got to like jump over stuff
but it's not, it's only a side scroller
so you shouldn't get motion sick.
Okay. I'm down for that one.
Okay. We are making this happen
because I love Super Bunny Man.
I think that would be really fun. Let's do it.
And I'm a bunny.
Pan it out.
Pan it out Bunny Burl.
I was going to say Bunny Burl.
Bunny Burl.
I still need to do my schedule for next week.
Hold on. Let me check my schedule for next week.
I don't think I've...
I haven't done anything.
I'm going to type in my schedule right now.
I don't think I've set it up but yes
if you set it up for next week
I can definitely
match it.
Match it. Yes.
I can do something.
I'm just going to ask for it.
Monday, Tuesday or Wednesday?
I prefer Monday or Tuesday.
What time would you like, my dear?
I prefer the evenings
but whatever time works for you.
Do you want to do Tuesday?
I can do Tuesday.
The 16th?
Yeah. 16th sounds good.
Okay. I'm adding that right now.
What time?
What time did you say?
I said 8.
She wants to do
8pm
Eastern time.
Okay.
Maybe we should do 9pm
so we don't overlap.
She didn't
schedule anything there.
I'm going to do it then.
My gosh, Tomas in chat.
Hi, Tomas!
Hold on. Let me watch the Tomas.
Tomas,
everybody liked Muppet Chibi.
Thank you. I love Muppet Chibi.
Chibi Mercy.
Get wrenched. Get your wrenched.
Get wrenched.
Get drenched?
I mean, wrenched.
Super...
collab
super bunny man.
Yeah, look at us.
We're planning some
shit.
Shit.
I have a...
I think I'm going to...
Yeah, I'm going to make my schedule.
My hair is mostly in the chat so it's fine. I can talk.
Yeah.
I think I'm going to do member streams on Mondays.
I can call them member Mondays.
That's really good. I usually choose
my members to be on Fridays.
Ooh.
Good for the weekends, hanging out.
Yeah, good for the weekend. They are relaxed.
Maybe they're chill.
If they go party and stuff,
maybe they come home and be like,
I want to just...
I can't even make that noise.
When does Emmy get back? She gets back today!
Emmy's back!
Whoa!
Yeah, Emmy's back!
I missed my little sister.
I missed my little Amutha.
We miss her so much.
I love her.
She's got some good stuff
on her schedule coming up.
Don't say anything. It's a surprise.
Sorry, I wanted to see what she was planning.
At least I think. I miss high beat up for her.
Yeah, I miss her.
We need to collab with her again.
That was fun.
Us three and Azura.
I want to have a collab with everyone.
Well, we have a collab soon!
Yeah, the rating thing!
Yeah, are you able to make
also the You May Plus watch along?
Yeah, I think so. It's in the evening.
Wait, what time is that?
Because that's on the...
That's in the evening.
Yeah, it's Sunday.
That's right.
You May Plus is having a concert.
We're just working out our schedules right now.
You May Plus has a concert.
I'm looking forward to it.
I think all the girls work really hard on it.
Everyone watches.
Or you can watch along with me, you know?
Yeah!
Excite.
For our member stream on Monday,
we're watching Twilight, no questions asked.
Don't fight me on this.
I love sparkly vampires.
I want a sparkle.
I wish we could gift
membership to each other.
Right?
So that we can watch each other's member streams.
Because I would love to watch some of your guys' member streams.
I wanted to watch Transformers
with...
Ronnie.
I'm watching Eagle Eye.
Eagle Eye? That's good.
See, I would want to watch that.
Eagle Eye is what made me into an entertainer.
It's my awakening
to acting and stuff.
Is that with Tom Cruise?
It's the one with Shia LaBeouf.
Oh!
Wait.
Shia LaBeouf.
Eagle.
I think I'm thinking of another movie with Tom Cruise.
I mean, Twilight's good.
Actually, there's a whole study on Twilight.
Which is really interesting.
Have I seen Eagle Eye?
Have you?
It's just showing me pictures of Eagle's eyes.
No, Eagle Eye like me.
I know.
Shia LaBeouf.
I see the poster,
but there's also just a bunch of Eagle Eyes,
and it's funny.
That's what happens.
Twilight, watch along.
Actual cannibal Shia LaBeouf.
Shia LaBeouf.
You're walking in the woods.
I can't wait to
shit on the Twilight movie.
I love the Twilight movie because it's so bad.
I kind of like Twilight.
In general, overall.
Did you?
I'm not like a Twilight hater.
I don't hate.
I just...
I don't hate hate.
I don't know how to explain it.
Overall, I'm just like,
oh, it's charming in its own way.
Yeah, I like to make fun of some
of the movies.
The books are definitely better.
It's some good cringe.
Exactly.
I'm Jacob because I like wolves.
I think I liked...
I had like a head canon ship.
Like, in my head
with like Alice and Bella instead.
Really?
I also really liked
Jasper.
But then I found out he was a Confederate soldier
and it just didn't work out.
What does he say?
I forgot that stupid line he says.
Jasper
Twilight
quote.
He said something really stupid.
I was
I was just like, yeah, I like Alice.
Alice is so... I had a big crush on Alice.
Alice was like...
And then I was like, Alice, please
get together with Bella.
You two would escape
these two weirdos.
I totally get the head canon.
All right.
Emmett was so...
Emmett was such a dude bro to me.
And I was like, yeah, I like Emmett.
And I was like, play football with him.
Alice was the girls girls.
She was. She was for the girlies.
Yeah, she was for the girlies.
I thought it was fun.
I don't remember most of it though.
I remember being in a book club that read it.
Because I just was like
I need something to do.
And so I joined a book club
and they were reading Twilight.
Oh, Nifty.
I feel like that's definitely a fun book to read
with other people because then you can just like geek out over it.
That's what happened in the past.
Alice, ex Bella had so many fanfics
and they were right.
I think the only
series that I like
make fun of
because it's the Twilight fanfiction
is like 50 Shades of Grey.
Yeah.
50 Shades of Grey is a Twilight fanfiction.
It's so funny.
They just changed the names.
But I read all of it
and it was not great.
It was not great
because there was a point where I had to
go back and read a few pages
because he was like
behind me.
And then I was like
and then he was
my hands were against the wall
and then now he's appearing in front of me
and I was like, wait, is he behind you?
How do you like appear in front of you?
I go under your arms.
What the heck happened?
I literally was like, wait.
Wait a second.
If you're against the wall
then how did he just go
right underneath?
Yeah, I don't
question it anymore.
Okay, I'm getting lost.
I'm getting lost
and I think what
I kept on cracking up
at my inner goddess.
Take a drink
every time she says like inner goddess.
Oh my god.
You won't make it.
I wish you'd do 50 shades and watch the log.
This book is enough to speak to your inner goddess.
I don't even know where my inner goddess is.
Just steps of crack.
It was funny.
I still have it somewhere.
I think my friend gave it to me as a joke.
Oh my god.
He's a porn
for
your birthday
and I was like,
thanks.
I remember being
10 or something.
I don't even know.
I was at the pool with some kids
from school because we were on a field trip
and we were all talking about books.
I thought I was being cool
because I was just like
I just heard a lot of people were reading 50 shades
without knowing what it was.
I was reading 50 shades.
It's pretty up there
book.
I was trying to flex on these kids
that I was reading 50 shades and one of the
school counselors came by
and pulled me aside.
They had it called
my parents because
my parents was letting me read 50 shades.
I was very awkward
and I was just like
I'm sorry.
I was just trying to be cool.
You were trying to be cool.
You just lied.
They were confused because
again, I grew up in a very religious household
because they're like, why is this Christian girl
telling everybody
to read 50 shades?
I think
it's fair though
the amount of
publicity
that book made, you'd be like
it's probably a good book, right?
It was the first popularized
smut book.
Everybody else just kept that stuff
behind closed doors.
You never heard about anything.
I remember
seeing on Tumblr
people were like, oh my gosh, I'm so in love
with this.
It was all the fucking screen caps from the movie.
I was like, oh, is it good?
And then I went to read it and I was like
This is something
I think I did end up
reading it later in life, like actually reading
the book and it's so bad.
It really wasn't edited.
I was like, okay, wait, is this a spelling error?
Now we get
some better.
I haven't read a good romance book in a while.
I'll read some trash.
I read Aqatar, a.k.a.
Court of Thorn and Roses.
It's not good, but it's engaging.
I think the last
book I read was like, gosh,
I've been reading classical literature.
Oh, nice.
The last book I read
that I can remember
reading was
The Robot Series
by Isaac Asimov.
Oh, that's a good series.
That's on my list.
100%.
I wanted to read some Asimov stuff.
The most recent book I've read
is The Atlas Six
by Olivier
something. I forget what their name is.
It's very good.
I love
fiction with a dash of fantasy
or what takes place
in the real world.
The Club of Mercy and Sheevee.
I'm going to do something like that,
but we all read smut books.
I'm working on that behind the scenes.
Don't tell nobody.
It's okay. I actually have a few books
that I'm just like, yeah,
if we can read free books,
you know,
public domain books, that would be cool.
Like, Moby Dick
or
You want to read Moby Dick?
I do love Dory and Gray
as one of my favorite classic books.
That was, I was like, oh my gosh,
I feel like I'm reading a fanfiction.
It was so
homoerotic. I think that's why I liked it.
Right?
I'm like, oh, the attention
is becoming basal.
I was Pujo Mines going
literally.
Invisible Man was good.
I think
yeah, I also have,
I was in the middle of reading.
Oh shit, what was I reading?
Maybe you should watch a
League of Extraordinary Gentlemen.
Have you ever seen that movie?
No, no, I haven't.
It's literally, imagine
an action movie,
but all of your classic literature characters,
like
Huckleberry Finn, The Invisible Man
Helping from Van Helsing
come together to fight
some evil.
And it's
Sean Connery's in it.
It's only, yes, Literature Avengers.
Oh my god.
It's great. That sounds great.
I was just going to be like, yeah,
we can watch films
like
I was going to just show like movies
that I liked.
Because I was like, I don't mind watching this
again, except for this one.
I don't want to watch this. A movie.
I don't want to watch this again.
What's your least favorite movie?
My least favorite movie of all time?
Like, disgusting?
Yeah, like it just like literally makes you cringe.
Oh gosh.
Okay, there was like a remake movie.
I was
so pissed off at.
It was about
surfing. I don't remember what it was called.
Hmm.
It was about surfing.
I was like, people were surfing.
And it's a remake of a movie.
It was like an action movie, right?
And then I was
watching the remake of it.
point break. Yeah, that's the title. Point break.
Point break? Oh, yeah.
I heard that wasn't good.
I literally
booed in the theaters.
I booed. I booed
in the theater.
I kind of think. It was so bad.
I like walked out of a movie recently
because I was just like
not. It was not good at all. I can't remember.
Oh, it's gonna bother me.
It was just like some
like I never was it. Was it Morbius?
More. It's Morbin time.
I was like
I don't usually
like boo but like
that was a movie that I had to be like
fuck that
sucked. Like I scream. I almost
it was like a nearly empty theater and I was like
that fucking sucked. I got
to watch it for free and I was like I want my money back
and I got it. I got in for free.
That's funny. Did you sneak in?
Oh, mercy.
I didn't sneak in.
I had a friend who worked at the theater
who was like here's a ticket for this movie.
People canceled or something.
I can't remember because they knew it was bad.
They just like
Oh, I love movies.
So I was like, yeah, let's go.
I was initially going to just like kind of
kind of relax in there because
it was kind of like a long day
and then I was like, oh, it's okay.
Even if I like fall asleep to the movie,
but of course I never fall asleep to a movie
because that's how like autistic
I
have to finish. You have to watch it and see it.
Yeah. And then I like watched it and I was like
this sucked. This like legitimately
sucks in every way. The acting
sucked. Everything sucked.
Oh, no.
Oh my gosh, Apollo. Hold on.
I got a wrench.
Wrencher.
Wrencher right now.
I like how we're still in the same call
and then Apollo, you can hop in any time
if you want.
Because we're still in the same exact call.
I didn't like the new Mission Impossible
movie. I was very let down by that.
That wasn't good. I don't actually remember
any
Mission Impossible movies.
I rewatched
Minority Report. That's a great one.
Oh, Apollo!
Hello. I hope that's okay.
Hi.
Sorry, I don't have your Fuji up.
No, you're fine.
She's a disembodied voice.
I'm the voice in your head.
Nothing new.
Just another one of my tulpas.
Gives you
your Muppet back.
Muppetize me, Captain.
I mean, if you want to include the model,
I still got it up.
Oh, yeah. She can hop in
our model thingy.
Oh, yeah.
If you want, if you want to know, it's okay.
I don't know how to do it, though.
I hope that I've added you on Steam.
Oh, yeah. We need to add
on Steam. We got Feast Dan.
Let's go.
Wait, I think you have to add
because we might have to add Mercy
because Mercy's like, Steam is broken.
I don't know. She couldn't add any of us.
I don't know why my Steam is broken.
It just decided like, I can't add people.
Poseidon's like, what's going on?
Give me a second.
I'm just going to tell her
that's the time
when you die.
I'm kidding.
But, yeah,
we're just
not now. We're talking about like
worst movies we ever watched.
It was the, I was saying, it was like
the new point blank,
the remake.
For me, human centipede.
Oh my god.
Human centipede.
Don't even get me started on that.
I'm not going to lie to you.
I have never watched
human centipede.
Good. Don't ever.
Don't, don't, don't, don't, don't.
But like, what if it's good?
It's not.
I'll save you the time.
It isn't good. Like, not even like,
oh, it's so weird. It's funny good.
Yeah, there's three. No, it's not even
funny good.
Dude, I watched all three of them when I was
sick. Oh girl.
I only watched the first one. I'm like, I'm good.
I'm good.
I was like, I don't understand it.
But I wanted to keep watching it.
I forgot that I asked
manager for our
logo and
he gave it.
Are you okay? He gave it to me like
two hours ago.
And I never noticed it.
Hold on. Let me go.
If you want to join
the thingy, here's the
password.
I'm going to DM you the password.
And let me just
add it.
I'm so sorry.
She asked like two hours ago
for that.
I don't know if you still need the logo.
Here you go.
I'm forgetful.
It wasn't Manay. Manay said I know also like
asleep.
Well, no, he like he I think he gave it to
me six to 20 minutes later
after I
asked.
So it wasn't like
it wasn't like too far off.
Okay. That's the password
and the server
we're on if you wanted to join.
Grab a blankie and
come on down.
Thank you.
And then we can like
we'll pop you in the middle.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Her laugh is so adorable.
She's like
scary movies.
The most recent scary movies that I've seen
are Smile
and Talk to Me.
Smile.
I thought you meant like scary movie,
the one that's supposed to
paradise screen, I think.
Those were great.
And then I couldn't remember which one was the original
and which one wasn't.
The Shane Dawson film.
No, not the smiley man or whatever the fuck it's called.
I thought it was the continuation from Shane Dawson.
No.
If you like horror,
watch it. Smile is good.
It's very unnerving.
I haven't had a unnerving movie watch
in a very long time.
It's not scary anymore.
It's just like jump scare and I'm like, okay.
I don't like horror movies that just rely on jump scares.
I like plot.
To me, a horror film
is
like a mystery, you know?
Yeah. I want to be thrilled.
I want to be unsettled and hereditary definitely have that.
I love hereditary.
It's such a great call back
to Rosemary's Baby.
Have you watched Rosemary's Baby?
Yeah.
It makes so much references to it.
It was so fun.
It was so fun. I really do think though
people who watch hereditary should
heredity?
Hereditary?
Yeah. Should watch
Rosemary's Baby.
I find a lot of horror
like
what's the word?
It makes references to past horror
horror films.
Yeah. I like the little nods.
Yeah.
Is that the one where they like
splice the DNA with this girl and this alien?
Isn't it the bald lady that's hot?
I think so.
Yeah.
I watch like a synopsis
because you never just like want to watch a movie
but you don't want to watch a movie.
So you watch this like YouTube or the AI voice.
Yeah.
That's me. I watch that.
Sadly, I can't join you guys.
You're giving me an error.
Man!
Are you doing a capital?
I was just kind of copy and pasted.
Oh.
Are you on Eastern North America?
Yeah.
Hold on.
Do you have to add me on urine from the list?
I think
Mercy does actually.
How do I do that?
Open up the
guest list and do the plus sign
and then invite. Oh, it's not working.
Hold on.
Maybe I'll just have to do it again.
Okay.
It's me. I'm the problem.
Oh, you're not! It's me.
Hold on. It's me.
I'm like the one who's not used to this.
I'm the problem.
It's me. There we go.
It should work now.
It should let you in.
Yay!
Yes!
It works!
Oh, shit. Chibi's gone.
Oh, no way. Don't worry.
I'll load in in just a moment.
I think everyone has to reload in.
Alright, I'm going to even come back.
That's me in the corner.
That's me in the spot.
Oh, by myself.
Oh, somebody's controlling.
You can't misbehave.
I'll tattle on you.
Why haven't I loaded in yet?
I don't know.
Dang. I think you're coming.
Oh, I see you on my end. Are you coming?
Yeah, I'm coming for you.
Wow, wow, wow.
You're going to make those noises for me tonight?
Damn. Just like that.
Wow, wow, wow.
Imagine? Oh, my God.
Be pure night.
I'm going to start doing that on my Patreon audios.
No.
Wow, wow, wow.
It's like I can hear their voices.
I can hear their voices.
That's so funny though.
Mercy.
No, it's not the girls.
A Christmas past.
Yeah.
What did I do in this lifetime?
That will make me forever shackled to mine.
You didn't shake your ass hard enough.
Oh, shit.
Anyways.
Why are you not loading in?
What the heck?
I don't know.
I'm leaving.
And I'm coming back.
Show model, show model.
Show model?
Show model.
Oh, you showed up on my end.
Oh, there we go.
I'm all by myself.
Oops, you almost saw that.
Yay.
I can pull you down.
Hey.
I didn't know that you have such a cool fucking dress.
Hello.
Yeah, your dress is so fantastic.
Thank you.
Hold on, let me move myself over.
She's so big next to me.
Ah, are you sheepsters?
There we go.
How tall Paolo is in like canon?
God is pretty tall, right?
Drop your height.
411.
Oh, she's small.
You're small.
Get down here.
I'm the tallest.
I'm the short queen.
Whoa, size.
Are you kidding me?
Let me show you something.
Oh, it's going to be fun.
She's a short stack.
Who's that sassy child?
Literally a sassy child.
Oh my God, she can lullify herself.
She defied herself.
Yeah, she defied myself.
I'm a creature.
That's so cute.
What the heck? I want that toggle.
Management.
Make me cute.
Oh my gosh, it's like suddenly you got like
bop-a-de-dead.
I can't, I can't.
That was so cute.
La critura.
I'm adjusting everyone.
I feel like we should play a game.
Like we should play like a sleepover game.
Oh my gosh.
We can gossip.
We can gossip about.
Do you guys have any hot goss?
Did you go to Anime Expo, Apollo?
Sadly, no, I didn't.
I'll be going to TwitchCon though.
Ooh, fun.
Sonic Expo in November with Fifi and
Chibidoki E.
Oh, nice. That'll be fun.
E, hopefully Hades too.
I hope Hades can make it.
I want to go to Akon so bad.
Me too.
I guess so shy.
I don't want to be alone.
No, I agree 100%
because this will be my first
TwitchCon in real life.
And I'm like, ooh,
I'm a little nervous.
Do you have any con stories?
Sorry, again?
Let's see.
We're having a really good moment.
I'm gonna be honest with you.
My first official con
was this year with the rest of the girls.
And
we had a sold out room
and I was like, ooh,
wow, that's crazy.
Damn.
There was a lot of people there.
That was just so awkward with everybody.
I was just shaking my titties.
As one should.
It was just like, I'll show off the feets too.
Yes.
Yes, as we should.
After all, those are the rigs
that people care about.
Hell yeah.
I wish there was a toggle where I could take off my heel
and just throw it at the camera.
Dude.
The only thing I can do with my feet
is just that they showed the beans.
Ooh.
My feet is like stationary.
It's not great.
Oh yeah, I forgot if your feet were up.
Sorry, my cat's food is going off.
That's one of the characters
on my channel is my cat's food dispenser.
I can understand that.
I have a lot of my cats would,
every single time I'm streaming,
they all come out of the dark shadows
and they're just trying to give my attention.
But when I'm not streaming, they don't give a fuck.
I know, right?
I'm just like, wow, okay.
Do your cats sit on your keyboard?
Oh, very much so.
Yes.
Yeah, I usually have like two,
there's usually a cat on my lap
and then a cat on the bed that's on my desk.
So that they, and then they sometimes fight over the bed
because they want to all just be there
and I'm just like, guys, please, oh my god.
I almost choked
on playing against
Radon for Elden Ring
because my cat decided to jump
off on my lap and in front of my screen
and I was literally so close
to dying.
That's so funny. I don't have pets.
I'm always like,
I love hearing people's pet stories.
I'm very much a cat lady.
When I tell you how many cats I have,
how many cats you got?
I have seven cats
and I take care
of one cat that's outside.
So like eight cats in total?
You have seven cats
and a bonus outdoor cat.
I have three cats.
I don't know what I would do if I had
eight running across my room.
I love
cats so much.
I'm very much a person
at heart that just like,
I just love taking care of animals.
That's so sweet.
Do you have any other pets?
Well, let's see.
They're not really pets and they're not mine
but I do have roosters outside.
I was just standing there with a rooster
because of a rooster crow
right before we started streaming.
I was like, is that her doorbell?
I was like, I have no idea.
And I'm like, how do you not know?
She doesn't know because
we stream at different times
and it just has not happened.
Because of like, she's your gen mate.
She has roosters.
That was so funny though.
Yeah, I have like
an area where I live.
There's like a bunch of chickens and roosters around.
We just have them.
I want chickens and roosters.
A few of them have little farms for us.
I want to lay an egg.
No, I don't.
Honestly, I just get happy because
they bless me with eggs
and I'm just like, I don't got to go to market now.
I know eggs are so expensive.
I hate eggs.
You hate it.
Oh yeah, that's right. You don't like eggs.
I usually don't like eggs but I need them to cook the brownies
that I've been sitting in my cabinet
and I'm very mad
because I need to cook these brownies.
Eggs, evil. I'm allergic. They kill me.
Please don't die.
My nemesis.
I can never escape it.
So you can't have mayo?
I can have vegan mayo.
Oh okay, vegan mayo is pretty good.
Yeah, it tastes like,
people say it tastes like
helmets.
Yes.
But like, I love,
gosh, it's like you have a little
farm outside.
Are we so convenient?
I want to get little chickens and goats
and dogs
and horse.
That would be cool.
So many animals.
Why do you have a,
did you just yawn?
No, Paula.
Me? Yeah.
No, I don't think I did.
Oh okay, because you're reading something.
Oh, because your face looks like this.
You were just like,
and I'm like, why does she look like this?
I was like, wow.
So basically,
I'm using my webcam right now
and
my tracking is not the best
right now because my iPhone,
I need to.
I need to have a prepaid
eSIM again.
Oh no.
Yeah, for my iPhone.
But you just need to be connected to Wi-Fi.
No, I'm in, okay, so let me tell you.
I set up
my VR setup in the garage here.
It's like super big, really big,
but the internet does not connect to my iPhone
over here.
And it does a pretty well job
except it kind of delays
like a few 10 seconds
and it looks really awesome.
So now I'm just like, okay,
time to go reinstall that
shit again.
Oh man.
In the garage?
Yeah, in the garage.
It's actually really nice in here.
I'm a little ketchup
ketchup, my little kitchen
here and my bathroom.
There's a kitchen in the garage?
There's a bathroom in the garage?
I want to live like a Paul.
With a little mini shower.
What?
Yeah.
So I just kind of...
Can I live with you?
I'll bring my cat.
I'll be a
good housewife
and I'll don you when needed.
Yes.
I have a lot to offer.
That is a big ass garage.
It is really big.
Are you sure it's not a house?
It's not a house.
It sounds like a
like an in-law
like if it's like construction
and then just like essentially put a little in-law in there.
Whatever they call it.
It's a free DOM arrangement.
Yeah, free DOM.
There are some
arrangements where I'm kind of like
surprised to hear about because I'm like
what do you mean you're streaming from
the basement or the shed?
Yeah, you know, it's just like
people stream wherever I guess.
I don't...
I still can't
fathom how I see streams
on just a laptop in the half as one screen
and does everything and when
she does her DJ stream
she only does it on her laptop.
That's amazing.
Get this one by the computer.
If you're watching, do it right now Snowberries.
Do it.
Yeah, she needs a computer.
Oh my god.
I just sit in a corner
in my open concept
studio-esque apartment
and just scream
and hope that my neighbors don't hear me.
I live with my parents.
It's like
wow, what am I doing? I live with my parents.
I'm a basement
dweller. I stream from the basement.
I have no pets.
I'm lonely.
I'll come over.
I'll bring my cats with me and then
you can have a good time.
Yeah, I can pet the cats unless the cats
hate me because sometimes they think
they see me and that they see that I'm
like visibly excited and they're like
not this one.
Oh no.
Boomi is very friendly. He likes everyone.
I'm so not used to it.
He's like a dog.
He's a big snuggly boy.
You have lots of pets, Kohai.
We're your pets.
Oh yeah!
I forgot.
Does that mean I'm a pet?
Am I Mercy's pet because I fell asleep
to that stream in my cage?
You can obby my pet.
I'm not used to being collared.
I'm the one who collars.
He likes pet play, Apollo.
Yeah, of course.
I'm so glad it's not like
a niche thing.
I feel like everyone kind of
likes pet play, right?
I like pet play.
Yeah.
It's nice. Do you like being the
pet or the owner?
I like being the owner.
Yeah, good switch.
I like to wear the collar and I like
to pull on it.
Some of my
hair members have sent me marrows
of them, how they bought collars recently
for me.
So they collared themselves for me and I'm like
hell yeah.
Hell yeah.
I love how all of us are just like
are just like, yes,
collar yourself.
You are mine.
Gosh, I love.
Well, ours.
This case.
Three girls abduct you
and make you into pets.
Vampire.
What?
Thank you Charlie
for this five super jet coal.
Hi, I have a confession.
Beside this is my mythos. Oh, please don't punish me too harshly.
Mods chop
his balls off.
Sticular
Corrosion.
Sticular.
I cast sticular torsion.
Chop chop baby.
Shit.
I said, torsion or
corrosion, my bad.
Or corroding his
balls or no, he probably wants this.
Don't give him anything he wants.
Whatever.
I feel like a lot of our
viewers have a, what do you call it?
Um,
overlapping
viewers with mythos.
Yeah, I've noticed that.
It's really cool. I know some people were just like
really happy to hear about the collab.
Mythos is like,
everyone was like super excited for
mythos. They're like, I love
them.
I feel like they're us, but
Twitch and we're them, but
YouTube.
You get the best of both worlds.
I honestly thought that
I was, I was so nervous
when,
when, like,
I didn't ask for a collab and I was like,
fuck.
It was a fucking joke.
And that's probably what happened.
It is probably what happened. I choked
on myself.
Only recently
heard of mythos. Everyone check them out.
They're really fun. They're beautiful.
Yeah. Check out the mythos girls.
Follow
on Twitter, follow them on Twitch.
Um, I'm definitely, oh, never mind.
I didn't fucking stream today because I'm like, I'll add their
links to my description. There's no stream
to be had.
But I'm assuming mercy will
probably on management do that or something.
They, I have their YouTube's
in the below, but I,
I follow you guys stream on
Twitch, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
They mostly stream on the twitches.
I want to at least attempt to try on
YouTube as just, I never done it
before.
It's a unique experience.
It's a little bit of a learning curve,
but I got it. I like to play
the game and don't get demonetized.
Yeah.
What am I doing
that will give me that lovely yellow
side
was literally playing a game
of
it's that little
cute game
that's like with the puzzles
that goes three combining
and then the girls get like
aroused.
Cutie.
Honey pop is a hootie pop.
Yes. Yes. Yes. That game.
And she played it on
YouTube and there was
a nipslip.
Oh, no.
She screamed so loud.
I hope that's a clip
because they want to see it.
I think she put it on Twitter because
it was really funny.
Oh, I have to hunt that down.
That sounds so funny.
Just like that.
You got like the snake noise
when he gets caught.
I was just like
that's some balls to play that
game on YouTube because I was like
I'm pretty sure there was something
there. I just can't recall.
Markiplier played it and that's all I remember.
Apollo is your favorite seagull.
Is that a seagull?
That sounds like you're howling.
I'm not going to lie to you.
You sound like a loon.
Not accurate.
You know, not like a loony
crazy person but like the bird.
The bird. The duck.
I don't know that one.
You should listen to it.
I remember. It's a very nice noise.
I had a friend from the UK come over
and then
I showed them the call of the loon
and they were like that's a wolf.
It does.
It sounds like a wolf howling sometimes.
You know how like grandparents
usually have like one animal.
They just have a lot of them in their house because that's like a grandparent thing.
My grandparents had a lot of loons.
There's like a loon photo in the bathroom.
They had like wooden loons.
I don't...
My grandparents were weird people but yeah.
That sounds like a loon.
That's amazing Apollo.
It exists?
Yes. It's a grandparent thing.
My grandmother
collected roosters.
My great grandmother also collected roosters.
I guess maybe it's just my family
that just collects random animals
as their special interests.
You're kind of right though.
Mama started to collect cows
for a little bit and it stopped.
I literally had
my other grandmother
was collecting those cows.
I'm like why?
My mom does frogs.
That's so true.
Some families just have
like so many things.
I remember going to my friend's house
and it was all frogs.
Yeah.
Families just have like a spirit animal that collects.
It's their family animal.
That's amazing.
Oh my gosh guys.
I'm so sorry but I'm getting so tired
and like I haven't had breakfast.
Or lunch.
Or dinner.
All right. Go eat.
Go eat girl.
I'm so sorry my angels.
I'm going to have to end stream.
Okay. Bye everybody.
Thank you for stopping by
hanging out with us after.
Thank you so much for joining.
Thank you Apollo for joining for the
Yeah.
Letting me crash a little bit.
The crash. I love it.
I love it. Join us more.
Well I just shrink.
So I will
send everyone
off now.
Is there anyone streaming right now?
There's no one streaming right?
Is Azura streaming?
Let me check.
Yeah Azura streaming. We can raid Azura.
Azura raid.
Azura Azura.
Say
Milky Wilkie.
Milky Wilkie?
Say her
her motherly advice stream.
So go yell
Mommy Milky Wilkie.
Yeah. Yeah. Mommy Milky Wilkie.
Thank you so much everyone for joining me.
Thank you Apollo. Thank you Poseidon.
And Mythos for
allowing us to be together.
And thank you Shibby for joining me.
So I'll see you guys
again next time.
Okay. Bye.
See you next time.
Bye.